The call,
is that okay?
Is that comfortable?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's where there's a constant debate
as to whether or not the headphones on
the way to go because the headphones or
the only way that you can hear exactly
what other people are going to hear when
they listen to the podcast so you can
kind of review it while it's happening.
Like if only I wear headphones than it
feels weird like I'm interviewing.
Yeah.
And it seems kind of to focus my
attention just on the.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Come back,
man.
Good to see Dublin from maps.
That's for whatever reason,
that acronym.
I always stumble with Multidisciplinary
Association for Psychedelic Studies.
Yes.
Yeah,
and actually I was just yesterday with
and today with Ralph Metzner and I got
the name from him in a way.
He wrote a book,
maps of consciousness and I needed a
name for the organization that had a p
in it for a psychedelic and so I was
looking around for words that had a p in
it and maps and I really liked what
Ralph did and with Tim and robbed us and
the rest and say,
I thought maps.
It helps
explain a territory.
Yeah,
well you guys are so important when it
comes to the dialogue of psychedelics
because from an outsider,
this is how I always viewed maps.
Maps is always like,
oh,
those are the actual really smart dudes
during the psychedelics because there's
someone who wacky fuckers out there in
the world of psychedelics and they want
to bring you crystals and talk to you
about channeling and I know a healer and
there's so much going on.
That's so crazy.
And then there was science and then
there was people doing actual peer
reviewed studies.
There's actual scientists involved.
There was real data and you guys were
pursuing it the right way and I was
like,
oh,
these guys are so important because
there's not a lot of people that.
That's one of the weird things about
psychedelics.
You could tell people that you went out
and drank whiskey until your feet went
numb and you shit your pants and no one
cares,
but if you tell people that you got
together with some friends and you took
a naturally occurring psychedelic drug
and you explored your consciousness and
you're so much happier now and you feel
better about life and you're more
optimistic if you do that,
you're some fucking wacky hippy Druggie,
some loser.
Well that's the perception and so we've
got this coming out and we've looked at
other social change movements like gay
marriage and gay rights and it comes
from people coming out because there are
loads of smart people that do
psychedelics or talented or emotionally
wise and they just keep it quiet so
people don't really know who in society
has had these influences and they don't
have to keep it quiet.
Either.
It's jobs think that their employees for
some reason would be better off if they
didn't do certain drugs,
certain jobs.
I think that's crazy.
The idea that they get to control your
body when you're not there is just
crazy.
Yeah.
But if you look at the companies like
facebook and Google
and all these tech companies,
they don't do drug tests.
They're better.
Nah,
they don't lose everybody.
Yeah.
They know the pot test.
Oh good Lord.
Oh my God.
They would lose.
The entire company would come back with
a real straight laced republican trump
supporting.
Yeah.
So the,
the innovation and psychedelics and
marijuana and looking at things in
different ways.
People are getting to appreciate that.
I think more the culture is changing
while we're in these camps.
You know,
we have these camps,
the do's and the don'ts.
Do you take drugs,
do not take drugs and you know,
and there's a lot of people that pride
themselves on one or the other,
whether they're a perturber or non
perturbed,
you know there's,
there's people that get weird about
people that are doing things other than
what they're doing.
They don't like it.
Yeah.
And that's why we need this kind of
coming out.
Yeah.
So we were having these global
psychedelic dinners,
and this is our 30th anniversary
actually,
tomorrow is the 30th year that I started
maps in 1986 and we're asking people to,
um,
in their own homes or with their friends
to invite people over and then have them
tell stories of what psychedelics have
meant to them or what their hopes are
for psychedelic research.
So you're inviting everyone to do it,
like on a,
like to make a night of it.
Yeah.
And it's like a Holiday Inn.
Yes.
Yeah.
During April,
during the month of April.
Generally you're creating your own
holiday.
It's,
well,
there's people that have done this
before.
There's,
with conversations about death with
dinner and drugs with dinner event.
So they try to promote conversations in
safe places,
but where people feel comfortable to
really be more honest and they can open
up.
And so it's kind of modeling on that and
then it hopefully helps people to come
out even more.
I mean,
we even have like a twitter,
uh,
um,
it's a Hashtag psychedelics because so
people can write in and just say
psychedelics matter to me because,
or you know,
I,
I'm,
I am more hopeful or I'm,
you know,
feeling that multigenerational trauma
can be addressed through.
Isn't that incredible that,
that is one of the best things for it.
Is Mtma one of the best things as far as
getting over traumatic experiences is an
illegal drug.
Yeah.
And yet there's a carved out area that
we've been able to make legal which is
the research area and it's because
science is the vehicle in our culture
that we trust more religion than our
religions.
And so it felt like science and healing
where the ways into the culture that was
freaked out by psychedelics in the
sixties and now because of these crises
we're in and also these tools that can
be shown to be really helpful and that
people have made life's out of them,
that it's not hurt them.
It's helped them,
but people don't it.
So that's where we think the research is
helping people create a space where they
can talk about it.
Well,
I think it's people are starting to
understand the true nature of these
things instead of the propaganda.
Then they're doing it from people like
yourself being really honest about their
experiences and people like yourself.
Even more importantly,
[inaudible].
There's not a lot of people like you
that have actually gone out and pursued
all of the significant scientific data
on psychedelics and the beneficial
properties to it so that we can
understand like we have this idea about
a thing.
Forget it.
Put all your ideologies.
Decide whether you're a right wing or
left wing.
We have an idea about a thing that's not
correct and this idea about a thing is
that there's a certain group of
consciousness adjusting substances that
are for losers.
They're for dumb people there for fools
and don't you mess with those and
everybody who does those is lazy and
Stinky and wet and you'll lock there
like people.
There's a lot of people that
automatically lock into that pattern of
thinking.
That's their go to for for any drugs.
Anything that's not legal,
but yet those same people oftentimes
will drink.
They have no problem doing that,
and they allowed times they'll take
pills to which,
which is even more bananas.
Yeah.
There was this idea that drugs are
marijuana hurts.
Your Iq says there has been to prove it.
Is that true?
Well,
the arrows,
a study,
the national institutes of health just
two weeks ago had a conference in
Washington at the NIH headquarters.
The head of Nih was there,
the head of night at the head of Nih,
national institute mental health about
marijuana and cannabinoids,
and it was a neuroscience review and
they presented results that suggested
that there was a heavy marijuana smokers
that started early in their lives over,
um,
this was done in New Zealand over like a
20 year period.
Had some differences.
Lower Iq than there
control groups.
Well,
if you're talking about people that are
smoking marijuana heavily,
one of the things that I would say is
that if you're smoking marijuana
heavily,
you're not going to do a whole lot of
thinking.
You're going to zone the fuck out.
You're going to do a lot of zone.
And out and while sober people might be
absorbing more information,
you're probably often worldly Iran all
day long.
That's not necessarily healthy.
I think all psychedelic drugs.
C should be an enhancer,
but they shouldn't be in replace of
like,
you shouldn't say,
you know,
I'm just going to be high from the
moment I wake up to the moment I go to
sleep every single day and this is how I
exist.
I'm just high all the time.
Hi.
Take a break,
man.
Yeah,
I had that
sense of as in my early twenties,
so smoking all the time to be high,
high,
high.
And I enjoyed it and I felt that got me
into things that got me really into
physical work and labor.
Really?
Yeah.
Fun and exercise.
Fantastic.
I mean that's the opposite of the couch
potato idea,
you know,
that people have.
But pod and exercise.
I'm just men.
I ran the New York marathon.
Willow stones.
That's amazing.
Tired in the middle.
And I walked into a Porta potty and
smoke some.
We jump back in.
Oh my God,
that's a great story.
Delirious lot of Jujitsu people smoked
pot for Jujitsu.
It's a big one.
Snowboarders.
Love it.
Yeah.
Snowboarders.
They say basketball players.
Yeah.
They say that.
It's one of the things about the NBA,
it's like you better not be testing for
weed because these dudes it when it
would make sense too,
because I don't play basketball,
but I play pool and it's,
it's,
um,
one similarity that they share is that
it's about touch and feel and touch and
feel is way enhanced.
A lot of the best pool player is also
smoked pot.
You know,
this guy,
a full blown up his spot to spot.
This is a video of me doing an
impression of him and he's like a
genius.
Fuck fucker.
They'll say it seems earl strickland,
he's a genius pool player and I,
he might have occasionally enjoyed
marijuana.
That's all I'm saying.
But um,
these guys,
like they say that,
um,
when,
when they're smoking pot and playing,
you can see things better.
You have a better sense of where the
ball's going.
You have more sensitivity as far as how
far it rolls.
Yeah.
I used to play racquetball a lot in
handball and a lot and sometimes I would
play stoned and sometimes I,
when I was,
she did have that deeper sense of being
in the moment.
You were just one step,
instant more into the moment as and
predicting and knowing and just um,
but I could never,
there was an unpredictability about it
so I could never really tell if I would
play better or worse.
That's probably why you play good
because you're never sure and you just
stayed on the edge.
You know,
there's a thing,
there's an ego dissolve in quality of
any of these psychoactive substances and
I think that ego dissolve in quality
gives you more space to move around with
all your other focuses.
That's my theory about it because I
always felt like,
like with Jujitsu,
you definitely feel better at Jujitsu
when you're high.
And I was trying to figure out why.
Well,
you also feel like you somehow or
another you feel more more vulnerable
yet you do better.
Like you're more like,
like kind of freaked out by any
aggression or more trying to avoid any
sort of conflict.
That's what the driving studies of
marijuana and drivers show that people
know that they're slightly impaired and
they take defensive measures and they
drive slower and more aware of the
possibilities of error as well.
Yeah.
And you're correcting for it and you
drive more carefully.
I think that's the part that
we have to really be the experts on the
risks as well as the benefits.
Yeah,
definitely.
That we can't ignore that.
There are both sides of it for sure.
With edibles,
edibles and driving settled down to
police settle down.
Are you sure?
You sure that's a good idea.
Yeah.
Although I think the idea we need to do
is more move to performance tests rather
than drug tests and then that's really
directly what you're concerned about and
then you need people's behaviors to
themselves,
but you checked their real performance,
not these indicators or predictors.
Yep.
From my personal experience,
there's a big difference between how you
understand and operate under it as like
someone who's been smoking pot for like
15 years versus someone who's been
smoking pot for like a week or a month
or even a year.
Like there's a difference in sometimes
your ability to handle being really high
like you,
your anxiety takes hold of you because
you're like,
oh my God,
and you start freaking out.
Then you can't drive,
you can't do anything.
And then there's people who that are
just,
oh Geez,
like that action Bronson Character
Action Bronson came in here.
This motherfucker smoked like nine
joints in the entire time he was here.
He just kept smoking and I had to tap
out.
I sit back and watch and he just never
slowed down.
He kept going in and kept lighting that
fucker up.
I'm like,
this guy's insane.
But like a dude like that,
that guy can handle being high.
He understands how to be high,
but for someone who's not really that
experienced that it man,
especially in a car,
it's not a good idea.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's got to be.
Again,
if you can just focus on performance and
it can.
It takes a while to get used to it.
I think what my point was,
the performance varies considerably
dependent upon the individual,
so I don't think you could even do like
an across the board performance tests,
like say,
Oh,
we've shown that this guy under five
joints can do BMX flips because a lot of
those bmx dudes,
they could do that shit drunk too.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I didn't have to be an individual
examination.
Yeah.
The the part that I really liked about
exercising and playing racquetball with
marijuana is that sometimes it would be
so easy to forget the score and then you
realize you're not really playing for
the score.
It doesn't really matter and you're just
so into the moment and playing.
Just Joanne.
Yeah,
just enjoying their movements and there
is this competition,
but it's about helping each other do
your best and then the score.
Yeah.
That's the one downside of,
you know,
your height.
I'll try and keep track of the score.
You needed someone there who's sober to
hire someone to do with a clicker,
but we can't be bothered.
Man.
Will you just give each of the
participation trophies like they're
doing with kids today where everybody
gets a trophy?
Don't worry about the score.
Just play.
Just keep playing.
Good one.
I don't know.
I think this idea though of science and
the being rigorous about things.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean I saw something that you did
about the aliens and I thought you did.
I'm like a TV documentary.
I thought you did great about it.
Thank very.
Yeah,
I was impressed.
The alien.
Listen,
man.
Nobody wants to believe more than me.
Nobody wants to be more than me.
Believe me.
I fucking want to believe,
but when I'm honest and I look at all
the evidence,
it's not their folks.
There's nothing there.
There's like a few people have seen some
stuff.
There's some people that wrote
affidavits.
Other than that,
you got nothing.
You got some shaky ass pictures.
That could be anything.
Could be a bird that got shot out of a
cannon.
We some of these photos that they're
convinced or from another planet like,
are you fucking serious?
Man?
I think it'd be anything.
He knows what that is.
I think the bigger question is if it's
true,
then what?
Yeah,
and that's what I've tried to look at
and so for me,
if it's true that there's aliens from
here somewhere else that are here,
what would I do differently in my life?
Do I really need to solve that mystery?
Which doesn't seem very compelling.
It doesn't seem likely,
but it wouldn't.
I think it's a way to be connected to
something broader.
It's like a spiritual urging.
I think it's a.
it's like a secular Jesus.
Yeah,
that's a really think it is and I don't
think I'm the only one.
It's not like I don't even think this is
my theory.
I think other people definitely thought
this up that there's some sort of a
connection between people that don't
want to believe in religion and don't
want to believe in any sort of ancient
ideologies,
but they desperately want some superior
and so they reach out to the skies and
some of them get fixated on the idea of
maybe even they have been personally
visited because it makes them more
significant.
It gives her life a bit more meaning,
you know you were chosen,
were testing,
you were trying you out conveniently,
always while you're dreaming,
but trust me,
dude,
it's really happening.
You're not just sleeping and dreaming
something crazy.
No,
you are actually on a spaceship and so
you get these people that are kind of
delusional and when you look at the
sheer raw numbers of people in this
country and then you look at the Ufo
story stories and go,
how many of these people could be
delusional?
Could it be all of them?
Could it be some of them?
Could it be most of them?
What's the real number?
And that was the the cold hard thing
that we got to on that Scifi show
because it doesn't discount the
possibility of definitely not of
extraterrestrial life and definitely not
of people being visited.
It's entirely possible that
extraterrestrial life has visited or
observed us and there was a unique
unique moment where someone was there
and witnessed it and maybe even those in
contact with them and then they took off
and they were gone and they never
returned again.
That is entirely possible because that's
entirely
what we would do if we could just go
from planet to planet as dumb as we are
now.
If we could just go from planet to
planet and do studies,
fuck yeah,
we would do it and if we found an
intelligent life form that was like more
primitive than us,
like cave people,
like some 2001 with the monolith,
you know,
if we found something like that,
you don't think we'd go say hi.
Of course we would say hi.
We would definitely say hi,
and then we jet back off at our fucking
sleep machine off into the skies.
We would do exactly what we think they
would do.
Well,
you could make the case that we already
know by looking at these tribes in the
Amazon that are as if living cave men
without much contact and we try more and
more now just to let them alone.
But when you go there,
they're wearing Nike's
fucking Koby Bryant tee shirts on Dev.
Like mickey mouse hats.
I mean,
it's weird.
You see these people in the jungle and
they have all this western clothing and
you're like,
wow,
it's so weird,
but yet they're living like an
indigenous tribe.
Yeah.
There's very few that are still pretty
uncontacted primitive and I actually did
a pod ceremony one time with some native
American church Shaman to how many
people can say that and,
but,
but this was,
a bunch of people can say that,
but they wanted to see what a friend of
mine who was helping them with their
sheep was,
uh,
using [inaudible].
It seemed to help him get stronger and
it was Mtma and so some novel,
it wouldn't.
When they would go off and do a pod
ceremonies somewhere else,
he would tend to their animals,
sheep,
ecstasy.
No,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
No.
Was it,
did you understand what he was saying?
The.
Okay,
I skipped those.
Just trying to follow.
I think we might've gone too deep for
this episode that I'm,
a friend of mine was living out with the
Navajos to kind of get his head
straight.
Okay.
And he would help take care of their
animals when they,
this male female shamans both would go
off to do pod ceremonies.
Oh Wow.
He stayed out there for about a year and
he kind of put himself together and they
said,
what helped you and we're interested in
what your medicine is.
And he said it was Mtma.
And they said,
well we'd be interested in trying to
experience Mtma.
So I was invited out there and we ended
up doing this ceremony in a Navajo and
they only spoke Navajo.
They didn't speak English at all.
And there was this like in the western
movies there was try a trail of dust
coming in.
Somebody came on horseback to be our
translator and it was there.
It was their 17 year old niece.
Holy Shit.
And she came
to mediate during this mtma experience
and it became clear that this was really
for her,
not so much for them to,
for,
for them to show their seminar,
who,
who's torn between the different
cultures that,
that something about our culture.
We wanted what they had or was we saw
and respected it.
Wow.
And the and a lot happened in and the,
it was wonderful in all different ways
and there are some important healings,
but in the morning,
um,
when we were going,
this young woman
was going to get back on her horse and
she had 17 magazine and was reading it
and that's where I started figuring out
that,
you know,
even out in the reservation in these
protected culture is that the
globalization of ideas and Internet and
five casts and people are being exposed
to ideas that they wouldn't have
normally been exposed to even in China.
I mean,
they're having to do so much just kind
of sensor stuff.
Yeah.
There's an explosion of thinking and
ideas going on right now.
It's a very strange,
strange time.
Yeah.
I'm going to come to that and I think
people are getting unsettled because
things they had thought were true and
rigid.
Part of their frameworks are,
are different than other places.
And how many people speak Navajo?
Exclusively.
There's a bunch.
That's insane.
I didn't even know that that existed.
I didn't know that inside of this
country's,
there were entire cultures of people
that speak in the original native
language.
Wow.
Yeah.
I didn't know that existed.
Well,
it's probably very,
you know,
thin at these upper generations because
the,
your younger ones are
arguably the best sounding.
Their language is like the coolest
sounding language ever.
It's got that vendor,
you know,
there's like a,
a sound to it.
Like there's something to their accent
that just A.
I guess it's like we're programmed to
think of native Americans.
It's like spiritual and authentic,
you know,
there's like this sound to it.
Like,
do you remember that scene with Clint
Eastwood?
Was it the outlaw Josey Wales where he
met that Indian chief and they got
together and these are my words of life
and also my words of death.
Do you remember that speech Jamie did?
I'm talking about dude,
you got to find the.
Is so powerful.
It's like one of my favorite moments in
a movie.
I mean,
those clinics should.
Movies were all ridiculous,
right?
Like when you stop and look at it is
they're all ridiculous,
but there was something to that genre
that spaghetti western genre because it,
it wasn't just that it was,
there were cool action movies,
but it was cool action movies that were
in some ways reminding you of how people
lived just a hundred years ago because
these were all in the 19 sixties and
seventies and shit.
Right.
That's when they did these fucking
movies will visit the 19 in 1870.
They were riding fucking horses
everywhere.
I mean this literally is a hundred years
old,
you know,
18,
65,
they abolished slavery.
We're only talking about a hundred years
and this cowboy western shit was going
on and for us it,
it almost like hearkens to a time right
before we fucked up the country.
Right when the first barometers on
wooden wheels rolled their platforms
covered in tarp across the entire
continent to find a spot to have babies.
Not that it was like this perfect
paradise for got here.
Definitely wasn't.
Yeah,
that's a.
that's an interesting perspective that
some people grab onto that the native
American people were completely a piece
where each with each other,
they definitely weren't.
There are amazing.
It's nothing to take away from their
cultures and I'm.
I'm fascinated by native American
culture.
It's just an amazing place that they
existed on and for so long without any
European influence,
while all this stuff was going on in the
world,
they were living here in a very,
very different way in a lot of ways and
intensely harmonious way with their
environment,
with,
with nature itself and I think we like
look at that and we have all these deep
spiritual attachments to that.
It's like it's like it means it's very
significant,
but they fought amongst each other so
much and that was their sport in a way
that they had that as killing.
It was.
It was a way of becoming trained as a
Predator and somehow that's so deep in
us and that's part of the question.
I think for me,
the psychedelics and therapy is.
Is there a way to get that out of the
human heart?
In a way?
I think the way to get it out as the way
that it's getting out right now,
and it's through information,
I think that when even you look at these
native American tribes that were
harmonious with each other,
right?
They have these very close knit bonds
and close tribes and they're very
communal,
but they didn't know these other people
that were exactly like damn.
There were a hundred miles away and they
assume the worst and they assume the
worst too,
and they looked at each other and there
was not enough communication.
They couldn't.
They couldn't interact with each other
instantaneously.
They couldn't get to understand each
other.
Like we've talked about this on this
podcast before,
but if it wasn't until like about a
hundred years ago where a boat showing
up didn't mean.
I mean if you were in the 18 hundreds
and a strange boat pulled up on shore,
you're Foxville right?
This is a terrible problem.
These are monsters with swords and
they're gonna jump off and they got to
shoot arrows at us.
That was really common.
If you got a boat that showed up a giant
boat and a bunch of people got off your
fuck man,
you just got invaded now that means
terrorists and you want tourist dollars
and people have translators on their
phones so they could speak to each other
that people that speak different
languages,
I mean is,
this is an amazing time.
Ms Dot amazingly strange,
but we're experiencing each other on a
much more even playing field than ever
in the past.
And I think that's how we can exist with
so many of them.
Yeah.
And I think if we can see that really
we're all more in common than we have
different and we can appreciate the
differences rather than be fearful of
them.
And that what we have in common is this
fundamental sense of connection of being
this web of life that really were not
virtually were pretty similar to
animals.
You know,
her way close the people at different
skin or different cultures
to be able to see that that
is who we really are.
And that acting from that and trying to
um,
work on cooperative solutions.
And I think that that's,
if we can have lots of people having
these direct experiences so that they
can't be manipulated by politicians.
So it's about grounding this kind of
globalization,
but comfort with
the sense of a connection that,
that were
able to find these bonds that they do
exist and that they can be built.
But I think one of the things that we're
seeing in this extreme oversensitivity
that we're experiencing right now,
there's,
this is like a really interesting time
as far as like pc culture and what's,
what you can do,
what you can't do,
and cultural appropriation.
I mean,
people are going after people for
cooking Mexican food that aren't
Mexican.
Yeah.
We're trying to call that guy cultural
appropriation.
We're trying to do,
take a Iowasca out of the,
uh,
Iowasca rituals and out of the jungles
and turn it into a therapy drug.
But that's out of respect.
It's not out of.
Well,
that's,
that's an interesting analogy.
It's a different thing and in a lot of
ways.
But yeah.
Yeah,
I mean,
culture is,
can evolve.
You just have to be acknowledging where
it comes from and try to bring you back.
You're taking.
Yeah.
What I was gonna say though is that this
oversensitivity is just a,
it's just a side effect of this expanded
understanding and in this expanded
understanding now all of the different
things that are injustices in the world
of being highlighted in a way that never
been highlighted before.
So then people start going after them
and then pushing the line further back
and then they start looking for other
slights that might be around,
you know,
other,
uh,
microaggressions,
anything.
What is this white people with
dreadlocks.
Justin Bieber adds fuel to the cultural
appropriation debate.
First of all,
ladies and gentlemen,
all you have to do is Google dreadlocks.
That's what I did.
And I found out that the fucking ancient
Greeks were like the oldest people that
wore greg dreadlocks like they,
they believe it might have come from the
ancient Greeks also,
like a lot of other cultures work,
dreadlocks,
vikings,
war,
dreadlocks.
This,
it's,
it's a cross the board with hair folks.
Okay.
This is not a black thing.
Not only that,
that's not what cultural appropriation
is,
kid.
That's just style.
What cultural appropriation is is like
save these native Americans had a
specific style of clothing that you.
If you wore it,
you were a woman and you were a sacred
person or you had a head dress that you
wore during very intense spiritual
ceremonies and someone just started
wearing that for fun.
Someone thought it was cool to wear that
for fun.
Well then it becomes offensive and
that's cultural appropriation because
you this,
these people have this ritual is very
important.
Sacred ritual in this one,
part of that ritual,
you are defacing your mocking it openly
and it's offensive to them.
It hurts them,
and even that's arguable.
That's cultural appropriation and I
agree that there.
I think if someone has something that's
sacred,
like a head dress or something that they
specifically were,
and then you walk around and wear it,
that's kind of a Dick move,
right?
If you have to earn that
someone.
Yeah.
It's like being a fake black belts or
having a fake phd or pretending that you
went to Vietnam and you didn't.
There's a lot of those people out there,
right?
They're all equally offensive,
but that's cultural appropriation is not
a white guy were in dreadlocks.
It's just not okay.
That's a kid who likes to wear his hair
like that.
Who gives a fuck and the only reason why
you give a fuck is because you've run
out of things that are really important
to care about in your life because if
you cared about really important shit,
you would concentrate on that.
That is a massive distraction.
If a white kid with dreadlocks is gonna,
you're going to go out of your way to
find anger in a white kid with
dreadlocks.
All that says to me is you need more
interests.
That's for sure.
You need more things that are
interesting to you.
Yeah.
That's called work avoidance.
You know,
you're just focusing on the things that
are of work avoidance.
Right?
You're right.
Yeah,
you're right.
That is a great way of approaching it.
It's exactly what it is and people do do
that.
Well,
there's a class at leadership at the
Kennedy school that I taught.
It was taught by the only psychiatrist
I'm on the faculty,
Ron Heifetz,
and that was a big concept was that,
you know,
as a leader,
there's just so much work avoidance
being done in different ways and how do
you help people focus on the issues that
are
tearing them apart or that they're
avoiding.
But it would be better if they try to
work on it and you know,
that word work is weird because work
avoidance doesn't just mean like actual
work,
like working on your job.
It could be working on yourself,
you know,
it could mean like there's a lot of
people that get involved in wacky
behavior because they also are addicted
to cigarettes and maybe they drink too
much so they start getting addicted to
wacky behavior as well,
not just as a side effect of the drugs,
but also to distract them from dealing
with the work they create.
Dramas they treat bullshit and all,
almost like to dis,
just
to drown out the nagging poking of all
the shit you actually need to get done.
So then he just fucking tank your life
again in this way.
Tank your life again and that way.
Yeah.
My favorite approach to a work avoidance
is doing lots and lots of other work
other than what's the most important
thing?
Oh,
really?
Do put off everything except like what
you really need to do.
Um,
I,
I catch myself doing that now and then
that's,
that's crazy.
Isn't it weird how your brain will just
play little tricks on you like is that.
I think it's this anxiety a bit about
this is a big challenge and you don't
know until you start how it's going to
turn out and there's lots at stake and
it's just,
it's a matter of what you tolerate from
yourself to.
And that's a weird line in the sand that
you gotta kind of learn to draw.
If you want to actually get things done,
you got to say,
okay,
now from,
you know,
7:00 PM to 9:00 PM,
I do this,
this is what I'm going to do.
I want to sit down and we're going to
work.
And you beat the boss of yourself and
then you sit down and you stare at the
computer screen or stare at the
notebook.
And you do the writing that you were
really trying to put off this hard for
people to do though because a lot of
times your brain is very wishy washy and
we see for our choices,
we receive our ability to open up our
websites and just start going and what's
going on and dig.com today.
Oh Wow.
That's crazy.
And then next thing you know,
it's 45 minutes after you were supposed
to start.
Yeah,
I call it the tyranny of the empty page.
It's just so.
But it's so nothing.
Yeah.
I sort of a weird thing to be terrified
of what really put me at ease was one
professor when I was working on my
dissertation at the Kennedy School at
Harvard and,
and I just had this idea that you had to
have it so good that you know,
to be,
were they and what I was doing,
it just
doesn't start that way.
So I had three professors but he needed
a fourth on my committee and he was the
academic dean.
He's terrific.
But I said to him,
you know,
should I,
um,
because you're so busy,
should I just worked through with the
other professors and then just give it
to you and the final phase just for you
to read over.
And he said,
no,
give it to me in the junk phase because
that's when your comments are the most
important.
But what it was got,
he acknowledged that there was a junk
phase and that helped me feel like,
okay,
I can start because I'm producing Janet,
but it's,
you know,
you just keep trying to refine it or
fight it.
Oh,
that's so important.
I mean,
should fear has this little piece of
paper that he has glued or taped to his
laptop and it says the first draft,
first draft of everything is Shit.
It's Ernest Hemingway and it's right
underneath the screen.
That's such a good point.
You really have to go over things.
Writing is weird.
And whenever I read something that's
like ponderous and just labored,
I did this.
You read this again,
you got to read it after you write it,
you got to write it,
you've got to read it.
And you've got to rewrite it and that's
where,
for me getting stone and editing stuff
that I've written,
it's harder sometimes I can write when
I'm stoned,
but it's very early and it sometimes
will be like,
um,
you know,
a half hour for a paragraph or so
because I'm thinking about all the
different words in ways and what you
used to write with.
I'm
to write with.
Do you have like particular software?
Do you write with?
Do you have anything?
I'm just Microsoft word.
Do you ever try right room?
Do you know what right room is?
Um,
no right room is this program where the
entire screen goes black and I'll show
it to the entire screen,
goes black and all you get is these
green letters and you can't access your
browser.
You can't,
you can't do shit.
This is what it looks like when I write.
Oh Nice.
So it's green letters there.
You could see it up on the big screen as
well.
Um,
so it's green letters,
black background.
And so when I write like that man,
I feel like it just owns me in and just,
I can't do anything else.
I can't fuck off.
I can't,
you know,
I just shut the Wifi off and Ram.
That's for me the best way,
the best way to get into it,
you know?
Yeah.
For me it usually takes a.
I'm being like midnight or something
like that.
Have you ever seen scrivener?
Scrivener?
Is scribner's pretty cool too.
It's something I've been using for
years.
It's this program that you can set it
up.
I think he set it up a bunch of
different views,
but the one I like,
it looks like a cork board.
So you have like index cards and you can
write on index cards,
see them up there like that.
And there were all those index cards are
expandable.
So each one of those index cards can be,
uh,
an essay and you click on each one of
them and then you get to notes and you,
you can,
you can open them up and read the full
extent of it.
You can highlight things and make notes
on the highlights.
It's really cool program.
I like it a lot.
It's really cool too because I liked
the,
I like cork boards and I use them in
real life and um,
I like,
I learned that from watching Sitcom
writers.
Do you can you have it where you've got
like the different columns or different
kinds of tasks and then you have them
prioritized so you can kind of in one
glance look at.
I don't know,
you'd have to explore that.
Only use it for notes,
but I'm sure I'm sure it's pretty
flexible,
but I think it's mostly a wow who,
who started using it.
I think it was a screenwriting tool
initially I think it was,
but a lot of people use it because it's
just a,
it's really cool of you.
What kind of stuff are you writing?
So mostly just bullshit.
Just my thoughts on things then extract,
stand up out of it,
you know,
I'll just,
I'll,
I'll write like long form things.
I keep saying that I'm going to get back
to writing a blog,
but I just never,
I never have the real itch to just tee.
I like,
like these half process things that then
become bits,
you know,
almost like use it as a farm I guess.
Like I used to try to like write a joke
or he used to try to write like
beginning punchline setup,
but then I realized like the best way
for me at least with my styles to write
a bunch of shit and then find out what's
funny about it,
you know,
is tweeting sorted for you like notes or
blog something useful?
Sometimes it is,
yeah.
Sometimes it's cool.
I like tweet.
I like texting,
tweeting rather because you only get 140
text characters.
Those 140 characters.
I think that's good because it makes you
economize and it makes you edit and then
it makes you,
it makes you a better joke writer and a
lot of ways like the actual,
like um,
the figuring out the slams and the
punches in a joke.
I think you can get to them better when
you learn how to say funny shit on
twitter because you only have 140
characters that small amount of text in
this little box.
And you've got to figure out a way to
get your point across and hopefully be
funny too,
you know,
sometimes it's just stupid texts to me.
Like someone will say something really
stupid,
just so silly and I just can't stop
laughing.
Like I think,
uh,
it's,
it's interesting like how tweets have
like a time where they work to,
you know,
like something could have just happened
the news and then some will have the
perfectly time ridiculous tweet and like
in that moment,
like that dude like cracked up the whole
Party of,
of the world,
you know,
or that woman or whoever the hell said
it is a lot of people that like a Jenny
Johnson who was in here,
she's become famous and a working comic
from tweets just from being funny on
twitter.
Wow.
You know,
it's amazing.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I haven't really used that.
Well you guys use maps using.
Oh,
we have tremendous.
Excellent.
You guys are really on the ball to when
it comes to social media and getting
people engaged and retweeting your
stuff.
Rice,
milk.
I'm Marie is in charge of that and he
does great.
We have such a seem yes,
right?
I
know you guys are amazing.
It's so,
like I said,
it's so important to balance out people
like meat.
You want balance out like me,
you know what we're in the stage of the,
um,
what I'm considering our major reality
check of our 30 years of existence and
that's submitting the data from Mtma
assisted psychotherapy for ptsd.
These phase two studies that we've been
working on for the last 15 years and
submitting that to first off to our FDA
consultants and then to Fda about going
to the next step about going from
exploratory studies to studies that if
they work then you get approval as a
prescription medicine as a prescription
treatment.
So we're,
we're bringing all of these data points
that we've gotten roughly just in this
bunch of studies,
around $7,000,000 studies over a 105
people.
And what we're able to tell is a story
about risk and a story about benefit for
posttraumatic stress disorder from any
cause with Mtma assisted psychotherapy
as compared to a placebo and also from
the literature and working with people
who have failed other medications.
It's a weird subjective subject,
isn't it?
Like how people feel.
How do you feel about,
you know,
your life because it's,
it's assisted psychotherapy,
like how much of an impact you
specifically can you attribute to the
drug,
right?
The,
um,
the test will actually determine that
because one group of people will get the
therapy with a placebo.
I mean this is how we're thinking of for
phase three and this is how some of the
studies we did with phase two.
So I think being rigorous and skeptical
is really important.
Super important.
So the first point is if you can do this
with the therapy without the drug,
then why do you need the drug?
But there's so many variables when it
comes to therapy as well,
right?
Like the relationship between the
therapist and the patient.
Yeah.
There's so many variables and ranges of
individual responses.
So there's these massive tables,
statistical tables for sample size
calculations that help you figure out on
the basis of all these assumptions,
how many people you need in this study
to get statistically significant
results.
And how many do you need?
Well,
we're still working through the
different assumptions.
I would say I'm an alien.
Let's get a million people highs.
Well,
just think of the cost though.
That's your problem.
It's got to be some billionaire
character out there.
Smart.
Once they're like Richard Branson,
Richard Branson started stitching out
them Dma,
then we've got a party there.
There are,
um,
support that we're,
we're getting.
That makes me very hopeful about our
ability to raise the money for phase
three.
We think it's going to cost around 24 or
$5.
Million Dollars.
Wow.
And we have about half of it already.
Either enhanced or committed a serious
shit.
Yeah.
Well,
the consequences if it works is that
then we can start setting up psychedelic
psychotherapy clinics for Mtma for ptsd.
We can start negotiating with the va and
the Department of Defense with their
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
The enormous,
um,
last year was about $6,000,000,000 that
the va spent in disability payments for
about 600,000 veterans that are disabled
to some degree with ptsd just for Ptsd,
just for bdsd around $6,000,000,000
every year.
Why?
Just in disability payments for,
that's why the human sufferings who the
money.
Oh my God.
Because the.
It's hard when people are traumatized.
I would've never guessed it was that
high $6,000,000,000 just for ptsd.
I would have thought just for disability
payments.
That's,
that's not cost.
One other thing.
And that's a lot of.
And what we're able to,
what we've been able to show what we say
in this group of a hundred and five
people is that,
and this is ptsd from any cause,
not just war,
but um,
childhood sexual abuse or rape or
workplace accident trauma of any kind
that a substantial percentage of these
people can have significant improvement.
And how that's valuated is.
Fortunately for us,
there is a independent rater
administered scale for not for symptoms
of ptsd and it's called the cap.
So the clinician administered PTSD
scale.
It's the gold standard developed by the
Va,
used by the FDA to approve Zoloft and
Paxil for ptsd and it's just been
revised from caps for to campus five,
so it's a work in progress over decades
and so this.
This is the objective scale and people
do have to tell their story to an
independent rater and the way that the
independent rating system is going to be
done is going to be a whole pool of them
that are calibrated with each other.
Interrater reliability and they know how
to administer this and they were
randomly assigned to what we think will
be about 230 people for one phase three
study.
That's probably what we're going to be
proposing and we need to have those
studies to large scale phase three
studies and what we're going to have is
these raiders will be randomly assigned
to one of the subjects and they won't
necessarily know is this the one year
follow up the two month follow up.
That really is the primary outcome
measure or the baseline.
So the independent raters are really
important because for skeptical people
in science,
the double blind is a key development.
How you do an experiment,
you shouldn't know the two conditions
she shouldn't know which is the
experimental one in which isn't because
your biases might make you suddenly see
what you want to see.
Right.
And it's very hard not to do that.
That's kind of a human tendency.
So the idea has been these placebo
controlled double blind studies,
but it's good in theory,
but with a psychedelic
use,
people tell if they've got a placebo
that does nothing or a psychedelic drug.
It's a fundamental problem of this
research and that's why these
independent raters are even more
important for people to have confidence
in the results.
And what we've tried is a series of
studies giving low dose Mtma and
comparing it to medium and full dose.
And so the idea we thought was that if
people are confused about which dose
they're getting,
but then we can show a dose response
relationship,
then that's the double blind.
That's the solution to the double blind
problem is that everybody knows they're
getting Mtma,
but they don't know what dose they're
getting and so you have to show the
people to get the higher dose,
do better than the people that get the
lower dose and the people patients might
not know.
Therapists could be confused that that's
the ideal.
So that's,
that's what we're heading for and that's
what we've spent the last 10 years or so
researching with different low doses of
Mtma,
25 milligrams,
30 milligrams,
40 milligrams,
75 milligrams,
101 slash 25 and we would always have
this possibility of half the initial
dose administered one and a half to two
and a half hours later to prolong the
experience and make it an eight hour
therapy session.
So when these people were getting this a
sec,
they're getting it or Mtma they're
getting it in a clinical setting.
Yeah,
they're getting it in a clinical
setting.
How often a w s three times three to
five weeks apart in case.
So that's.
And it's a three and a half month
therapy process of weekly psychotherapy.
So the emphasis is on the psychotherapy,
the preparation,
the therapeutic alliance,
and then after three weeks there's the
initial MTMA session and it takes place
in a special treatment center treatment
room where there's a male,
female co therapist team with the
person,
the person,
the patient is having their blood
pressure monitored,
they're having their temperature
monitored,
they're being videotaped,
the whole thing.
And there's video tapes on the therapist
as well.
We're trying to understand about the
method and the experiment.
This portion of it,
the session is about eight hours
treasonous.
Who's auditing all this footage?
We are,
we've loading it up or we don't.
Um,
we're,
we're not having somebody audit all of
it.
We have the therapists.
I'm sort of note which are the decisive
moments.
So I stuff on youtube,
we're developing.
This is.
Yeah.
Actually.
So in order to train therapists,
the best way to train therapists is to
show here's videotapes of actual
patients under MTMA.
And this is how they're,
it's poetry,
it's,
it's Po,
it's symbolic poetry.
People talk in terms of imagery because
half the time their eyes are closed.
I'm listening to music having just their
own private experience,
the other half of the time and more or
less they're communicating with the
therapists
and it varies and there's no particular
order of things.
So it's basically,
and this is what I felt with the native
Americans with the,
when we did Mtma with the pod circle,
that they had these elaborate rituals
that,
you know,
we went through the whole night that
were beautiful and filled with these
rich symbols.
Um,
but then they went,
so they did some of their opening
prayers and they want to know what we're
going to do and we didn't have anything.
He was like,
well,
we just sit around and somebody says
it's kind of a more free form.
It felt that we had like a poverty of
ritual,
but also freedom to,
to explore like that.
And that's what we try to provide in
this mtma experience that people have
their unconscious as the guide.
And we're not the guide.
We're not steering them anywhere.
There's all these techniques.
We know we're not a,
we're responding to this emergence of
material that's been catalyzed by the
relationship,
the setting.
And then the drug and we're supporting
this emergence and different people will
sometimes go to the trauma first or not
talk about it till the fifth hour or
they'll go to childhood experiences that
were supportive to build strength or
they'll be,
but often it's in the symbolic language
and they're sort of telling themselves a
story.
Wow.
And that story can reorder the neural
networks and their brain and deemphasize
activity in certain fear centers of the
Medola and can change how memories are
stored.
We're just sending Mtma to Rockefeller
University where one of the leading
scientists and anxiety is going to start
some studies when animals,
mice,
rats,
I'm not sure which,
um,
and trying to look at fear extinction
and memory reconsolidation and how mtma
effects that.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So we're starting to get,
I fear extinction,
but through giving someone mdm may at
least lessons anxiety.
Yeah.
So it,
it means that when you have memory,
you react with fear all the time.
That's.
And this,
this fear has never fully been
processed.
It's always like,
it's about happening.
It's not been fully processed because
it's been so scary.
Right?
More emotionally rich.
Jay,
so with the Mtma you can help people
through this way of reducing the fear
response,
their activity and they mingle is
reduced.
Wow.
And so people can
have the content without the fearful
emotion.
So as some sort of a bridge or a
blocker,
a yes.
Yeah,
but it changes the structure of a memory
to that person because
it changes how the.
Ma'Am,
every time you have a memory you have to
consolidate from different parts of your
brain.
Then you reconsolidate the memory.
Yeah.
That's why people have weird false
memories,
right?
Yeah.
They would swear were real.
Your memories change over time,
but it's a memory of a memory that
you're retelling.
It's almost like you're like,
if someone you know that had a story and
they did something and they told it to
you and then you tell your friends about
that story,
that how,
Hey,
I know Bob's story.
Let me tell you Bob Story,
but you don't really know Bob's story
because you only know it from him.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like you weren't there when it happened
and I think that's some of what happens
with Lee's,
my memories as they get older and older.
I'm like,
what is this?
This is a memory of a memory that I had.
Yeah.
You have to double check.
Yeah,
a lot.
And what happens is that people's memory
for the trauma actually gets better with
Mtma.
You can somehow another change what that
memory is.
No,
you know,
that's the beauty part of it.
Do you change your reaction to them?
But I mean with that is to you like the
feeling tone.
Yeah.
So,
so because these memories were so scary,
they've been suppressed but,
but not successfully.
They're not fully integrated.
Still activating fury actions on
frequently and so when you can feel
peaceful and then bringing up the
memories and then because you're feeling
peaceful,
people remember even better.
You know what you guys should really do.
If you really want to prove the effect
of city of effectiveness of Mtma,
you should go to Worldstar hip hop.com
and find all those people that got
fucked up and give them ecstasy and see
if it helps.
Because there's so many people that got
punted in the head and thrown off a
fucking building.
We have the Zendo project.
Is that for Worldstar hip hop.com
exclusively for electronic dance music
festivals and burning man.
I'm done.
Definitely different.
Yeah.
But I mean the idea of being able to
better process trauma is universally
appealing.
I think all of us have had bad moments
in our life that probably overcome.
And you,
you know,
you probably have some character because
of those moments,
but it would be nice if you had a full
handle on how it makes you feel.
Yeah.
And,
and that's where this memory enhancement
comes in handy because then you can
really learn from what happened.
Can I ask you how you chose Mtma out of
all the different psychoactive
substances?
Yes.
Um,
I felt that MTMA had a chance of being
welcomed into the culture as the first
of the different psychedelics because it
has that fear reducing.
It's not so psychedelic.
It's not a classic psychedelics.
Yeah.
It,
it doesn't make you feel like you're
losing control.
It makes it so that you feel a subtle
shift of openness to self acceptance and
self love and self acceptance I think is
like the core of it,
and your muscles relax.
People can stretch a couple inches more
really when are more limber on Mtma.
No kidding.
Yeah,
yeah.
Have you,
have they ever done that with athletes?
Um,
I don't know.
They should do it with athletes like
people that are already really flexible,
like maybe jazz or something like,
and that's the Yoga people and I've done
martial arts people.
Yeah,
you can do.
I think that's part of the muscles relax
and that part of your attention is,
or it's tense because of parts of your
brain and so that the way in which you
can then have this full memory when
you're feeling peaceful and you're
looking at it as if it's happened in the
past,
which it did.
So you finally got this perspective on
it because this piece makes it so that
you're.
You're not seeing it as happening right
now because you realize it's not
happening right now.
It happened then.
And so you're creating this longer,
different kinds of memory storage of
something that was clearly in the past
and it's connected now to this
reflective,
peaceful tone.
So when the memory has reconsolidated
restored,
the next time you call it,
you'd get the incident,
but you get the emotional tone of this
peacefulness and that it's in the past.
And so you can do work within a period
of minutes,
sometimes hours of seeing a shift,
um,
and looking at something differently and
processing these traumatic memories.
It's rare,
but one person was in our study and he
dropped out after just one session
because like I got this is like
part of what he got.
Tony macy is his name,
was one of the vets.
And part of what he got was that he had
been telling himself that he was on
opiates for pain,
for injuries,
but that he was starting to realize it
was really more of a escapism and that
he didn't need them and he didn't need
drugs and he didn't need Mtma or wow.
He didn't need anymore.
And he,
he'd had what he needed and will.
Kudos.
Yeah.
And we asked them later if,
um,
if,
if he would at least be part of our
followup evaluations,
and he said yes to that,
well,
that's nice of him.
And so he didn't have a,
it wouldn't qualify ptsd at
the two month.
And then when it got closer to like the
one year,
which is our last follow up,
he started saying,
well,
you know,
I'm still feeling pretty okay,
but I think I could learn more from md,
may,
maybe can I have now some more of these
sessions.
And we said,
well,
it's a rigid protocol you've dropped
out.
Um,
but let's just wait and see if you even
would qualify to be in the study if you
even have ptsd.
So we did the 12 month followup and he
didn't have,
he wouldn't even qualify to be and still
wanted to give some exit off you because
there's other things to learn how good
it feels to me.
Trying to party party under the auspice
of scientific study.
And,
and in order to be the most rigorous
too,
there's a way to look at studies.
One is called the per protocol.
Everybody that finishes the study and
meets the criteria and the other is
called intent to treat,
so that means everybody that comes,
you got to look at their data.
Even if they drop out or they lied to
get into the study or they wouldn't have
qualified or whatever it is.
Once you have enrolled somebody that's
the more conservative,
you just have to include everybody.
You can't just be picking the people
that fulfilled your treatment plan.
Right?
So this guy was a part of that.
We couldn't normally count them,
but now that we're doing the most
conservative intent to treat analysis,
we can include the dropouts.
So actually Tony Scores of massive
reduction in ptsd symptoms after just
one session counts in our data.
Wow.
Because he was screened and had the
first session.
There's so many variabilities,
happiness being such a crazy sort of
unquantifiable thing,
right?
That's what everybody wants.
Everybody wants some happiness and one
of the things that Mtma does seem to
provide a lot of people is relief from
tension,
which in a lot of ways equals happiness.
I mean,
if,
if you know universally,
if you had to say what is the one thing
that people get from a drug called
ecstasy,
it's you feel great,
right?
You feel relief,
you feel comfortable,
insecurities melt.
They just dissolve.
They don't,
they don't exist anymore and you can
approach people in this really weird
open way where you're not constantly
ready to judo,
whatever kind of bad shit they're
sending your way,
like so many people when they
communicate,
they always have some sort of a wall up
or some sort of a barrier between their
real feelings and what they're
projecting so that they can sort of
figure out how to navigate this
conversation with the least amount of
social damage.
You know?
I mean it's like this is like a zen to
some styles of communication like this
way of going through it with having the
least amount of conflict in your life.
But if everybody was on ecstasy,
that would be the vibe like this.
There's a vibe that you get and I'm not
saying everybody should do it or what
I'm saying is,
is a vibe that you get when you
communicating?
I accidentally,
it makes it almost impossible to
have arguments with people.
It gets weird like you communicate with
people in this open way that you will
never even attempt if he weren't both on
Mtma yeah,
we actually have a study starting in the
next month or so where we're going to
give to people Mtma at the same time to
a couple a dialogue of,
well these are already people that are
related,
but one of them has ptsd and one of them
it affects the relationship but doesn't
have ptsd.
And so this was,
um,
a major,
major breakthrough because I'm,
the first study with psychedelics was in
the modern era was 1990 with Rick
strassman with a dmt study.
Uh,
and ever since then,
now for the past 26 years,
it's only been one person getting Mtma
or psilocybin or Lsd or anything at a
time.
So this is the first time we've been
able to work with two people at a time
and give them Mtma.
And it's also the study that's in
informal collaboration with the Veterans
Administration,
National Center for Ptsd.
It's a therapist that used to work
within the national center who's now at
Ryerson University in Toronto,
who develop this approach and who was
introduced to us through the work of
Richard Rockefeller who was opening the
doors for us with the National Center
for Ptsd and we met this woman,
candice Monson,
who's the researcher,
and she's developed what's called
cognitive behavioral conjoint therapy
and conjoint means couples and so it's a
cognitive behavioral sort of scripted
how you kind of think about your trauma
and exercises about it,
but it's for couples and so when they
were thinking how to blend Mtma with
traditional non drug psychotherapies
that are used by the va,
the couple's therapy they thought would
be the most logical because it helps you
to have those kinds of communications.
You're the better listeners.
You're more empathic.
Yeah.
You can get over stuck arguments and the
ptsd really does affect the relationship
and in a lot of ways and there's.
The researchers have all these measures
of the relationship with the style of
communication between the people.
We really care about the caps,
the clinician administered ptsd scale,
but it's going to be tremendously
exciting and we've been able to get
permission for the first time to give to
people MTMA and we'll be able to monitor
that,
but couples therapy,
even though it's a tremendous use of
Mgma,
will never make it through the FDA
because you can only take diseases.
You don't have to treat a disease.
It's not for personal psychotherapy,
which is not,
you know those things.
It could be anxiety disorder or ptsd or
depression.
We have to treat diseases.
It's such a weird distinction there.
If there's something wrong and you have
a substance that makes that wrong,
better,
why?
Why does it have something wrong?
Have
to be something you look at in a petri
dish.
Well,
only because of the drug war.
It's only because it's illegal.
Otherwise it doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
it's obviously there's a condition and a
solution to that condition mean this is
the fact that you're not dying from
feeling like shit about your marriage.
It doesn't mean there's not a problem.
You know?
I mean,
that's so stupid.
Yeah,
it will be one of the best uses of Mtma.
I mean that's like making toothpaste
illegal.
It's like,
you know,
the,
unless you have like a serious dental
disorder and you really need to clean
the holes,
like you have some sort of a horrible
root canal that's about to happen.
It's the idea that you can somehow or
another key people from doing what they
wanna do.
That's at the heart of it all right.
Right.
And,
and I think that the,
this idea of,
again,
the psychedelics because Hashtag
psychedelics because of coming out of
the closet of people
saying that that this has been helpful
and that this is something good and we
should be able to do this.
And um,
I think the eventual use,
we're sort of backing into this use in
couples,
but it's really about making empty
manger medicine for Ptsd and it's also
about trying to understand what's the
drug and what's the,
the context.
So while we had this context I was
describing of this non directive therapy
of the unconscious being the guide,
other people like cognitive behavioral,
they give you all these exercises to
think about.
And how you think about your trauma and
we're and when it,
your triggers are and all different
kinds of thought exercises.
And so we're seeing that MTMA is like a
general tool and so we're,
because it's nonprofit drug development,
we're trying to work with as many other
therapists was,
as many other,
uh,
combinations of treatments that they
want to use to explore if they want to
blend Mtma with it.
And so we have this 960 grams of
worlds.
Some of the world's purest am.
Don't tell me where it is
made by Dave Nichols at.
Don't even give up the dude's name.
They're going to hold them hostage and
make them.
Now this was a,
a lady had legal permission,
legal MDM.
This is all legal.
What I'm saying,
1985.
I had a kilogram made.
Oh my God.
And that's what does that two pounds.
I'm two point two pounds.
Two pounds.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
And googling Mowgli young Jamie.
And this.
This was
in the department of Medicinal chemistry
at purdue.
Oh my God.
They got a better yield than they
thought.
They got more than a killer doll.
Yeah,
but they did,
they started off with it and the whole
night I only paid $4,000 for it.
Did you guys ever do a rave while you're
making it?
Absolutely not.
Oh,
I'll read that you at all.
But way to go.
We just stick to the script.
Yeah,
no,
that was,
this was,
you know,
there's like the legal track and
understand.
Yeah.
That's why the yield was totally off.
No,
it was all right.
So
we have a 960 grams left 31 years later.
It's Christ and it's still the exact
same thing we're using in our study.
So 31 years later it's the,
you know,
it's kept in a room temperature and
without light,
without moisture.
It's just infuriating that it's taken
this long for people to recognize what
other people have said for the other
people said for a long time.
And I understand the idea of having
rigorous scientific testing,
but at a certain point in time it should
be,
there should be enough anecdotal
evidence and lack of,
for me,
I mean,
how many people died from Mgma?
Has Anybody?
Um,
yes.
Yeah.
What are the risks?
What is the ld 50?
Yeah,
well,
I'm ld 50 is a measure where you give a
bunch of animals increasing amounts and
the amount where you kill half of them,
right?
Um,
the ld 50 of 'em empty main humans.
I don't actually even know that number.
Um,
but it has happened.
People have people they died from it or
they die for.
I know people have died from dehydration
have died from hyperthermia.
Right?
So mtma affects your temperature
controls,
which is one reason we measure
temperature,
although in therapy,
but in a clinical setting,
line down,
there's no problem with temperature at
all.
Um,
and normally there wouldn't be either.
If there was adequate harm reduction and
people were drinking,
not just water,
but I'm electrolytes.
Um,
and they would take time.
People are always so sweaty is I was
going on there sweating,
but the dance a lot too.
It's that combination.
So some people have maybe glowsticks,
pacifier,
glitter,
glitter.
I know my analogy about toothpaste is a
bad one,
know toothpaste and teeth,
but there is,
there is some weirdness to this idea
that we need a substance like gets
classified whether no matter whether
it's legal or illegal,
it's gets classified and when you make
something a drug and that drug can only
be used when there's an ailment,
then you lock out the whole possibility
of performance enhancing substances
like,
well we can't.
I mean we,
we don't disclude across the board
performing,
enhancing,
enhancing substances.
I mean that's essentially what coffee is
and it's mandatory.
I mean,
coffee breaks or written into union
bills.
I mean all the,
like when they make a contract,
they've write in coffee breaks.
We've always had coffee breaks,
right?
That's a break to take a drug for
productivity.
And it used to be illegal at one point
where people gathered together and talk
and revolution in England.
Incredible.
So it's like many other things.
So we,
this one,
performance enhancing drug will ecstasy
is probably a performance enhancing drug
as well because it gets rid of some of
the bullshit that you've got clogging up
your thinking.
Right?
And it allows you to think more freely.
And you can.
It's,
it's,
it's the most inherently therapeutic of
all the psychedelics.
So when you asked me why did I choose
Mtma,
I think one part is it is the most
inherently therapeutic.
People tend not to have bad trips.
That kind of bad trips people have is
when they take Mtma in a recreational
setting and difficult emotions come up
and there with friends that just want to
party and they tried to stuff the
emotions down and someone plays slayer
and real loud or that would be worse
too.
And then they end up worse off.
So MTMA can make people worse off toe.
Well there's certain people that really
shouldn't be allowed to chew gum and we
should take them into account too.
There's certain people that are going to
stub their toe every time they walk.
And I don't think we should know if the
world okay.
It's super important to recognize when
you're looking at all these numbers and
statistics that there is a certain
percentage of these people in this world
that are helpless.
You just can't do anything about them.
There is everything,
if you look at,
I'm skiing,
look at the number of people that die
running into trees.
I mean,
every year there's about 35 or 40 people
that die skiing.
Every year.
Two,
we lost Sonny Bono.
You'd have to remind me.
Yeah,
I have to bring it up,
throw salt.
And that's not even counting people with
avalanches.
But,
but that's because there are benefits
and that's where again,
this coming out,
it's fun schemes.
Fun but the,
you know,
so it was driving race cars.
That's fun too.
If there's a lot of stuff that's fun but
dangerous.
Look,
there's a lot of dangerous activities,
but the amount of people that actually
die from ecstasy versus skiing,
very low and very.
A lot of people take who skis ski more,
take ecstasy more.
Um,
I think that a lot of what people think
is ecstasy is exiting.
Meaning Mtma is really something else.
So that's another problem is right
around the half of it.
I'm like math,
right?
With erowid.org,
there's an ecstasy pill testing program
that they have been conducting that we
helped start years ago.
People,
there's one licensed laboratory licensed
by the dea and the United States that
can take anonymous samples of drugs.
You can get drugs tested,
and so there's been this program to get
ecstasy.
Pills tested over eight or $900 have
already been tested and around half of
them don't even have mtma in them.
Jesus Christ.
So there's they mostly amphetamines.
They're fed means their caffeine.
A lot of pain pills.
Yeah.
They're selling them as excess.
Sometimes they would,
um,
there there's test kits that dance safe
cells and sometimes,
um,
to pool the test kits which turns a
certain color if there's Mtma in it.
There's been pills that are one part
mtma nine parts.
Caffeine.
Wow.
Because there is the stimulant aspect
and people stay up.
It's a terrible up,
but the risks of Mtma
even in a large recreational setting,
if,
if it were a post prohibition world,
those risks would be very manageable.
But there would be some people,
probably a rare situations,
somebody might die.
We have that all the time with cars,
with alcohol,
with,
you know,
I can't say that it would never happen.
It's like those freaks that are allergic
to shrimp,
right?
Or Venice Hillen people die for.
Yeah.
This is going to be risk for everything.
There's nothing that's safe.
100 percent.
Even salt.
Salt kills people who die from salt over
doses every year.
Right?
Aspirin.
Aspirin kills people.
Yeah.
Some thousands of people die every year.
But the actual.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's crazy.
The number of people that fall in their
bathtub and day and to foods get rid of
bathtubs to make them all out of rubber.
And so one of the things that,
um,
my wife said about me when,
uh,
some of the neighborhood teenagers when
we had our teenagers were thinking of
coming to visit me at boom festival in
Europe,
which is one of these festivals where
they have the most harm reduction.
Um,
and these were teenage boys.
And what my wife said about me was that
I wasn't really good at prevention,
but I was good at rescue.
Mm.
And so that's for me,
the prohibition versus public health,
you know,
prevention,
public,
you know,
prohibition.
But if we can be good at acknowledging
the risks,
but being prepared for them the same way
that festivals have medical tents and
people have all sorts of physical
problems,
but the problem is there's not a strict
prohibition on dangerous things.
So the precedents already been set of a
freedom.
That precedent of freedom.
We would like to extend across the
board.
We.
That's what we want.
We don't.
You can't tell me that I can go to a bar
and drink my fucking lungs out and smoke
cigarettes all day long and I can take
pain pills and I can do all these
things,
but I can't have a joint.
You can't.
You can't tell me that.
It doesn't make any sense.
Did you see the quote that was recently
circulated on the Internet by Erlick men
about the origins of the drug war?
I did see that repeated well what
basically he said that Nixon,
when they were looking at the protests
that were being conducted by the hippies
against the war,
against a lot of Nixon policies and the
blacks who are arguing for civil rights,
that they knew they could not make it
illegal to be black or illegal to be a
Hippie,
but they could look at the drugs that
those groups were using and selectively
criminalized and prosecute them and use
them to break up those communities and
that they knew they were exaggerating
the science and that the drug war was a
political war against certain kinds of
drug users who were considered to be a
problem to Nixon and Ehrlichman and this
was something that they will come and
said,
I'm 20 years ago.
It didn't get that much attention and
he's been dead I think 10 years now,
but it just came out again in an article
and people are looking at what
Ehrlichman said and it seems intuitively
true.
Intuitively true in just unbelievable
how damaging
and for how long.
I mean,
it's been going on since 1970,
so we're,
we're deep here.
Yeah,
but it also had triggered into a fear of
the unconscious of fear,
the drugs,
not just these political parts,
but just the drugs themselves and the
reasons why they were political with
also the blanket label of drugs becomes
really problematic because you have all
these things lumped in together.
You've got heroin and marijuana in the
same categories.
You've got cocaine and all these things
that are so different and to call them
all drugs,
it,
it's,
it's not a good implication.
It doesn't make sense.
It's not a good distinction.
Like there should be obvious
classifications like we all know,
like I say,
you,
you asked me about,
uh,
you were telling me about the ecstasy
and I immediately thought amphetamines.
Well that's a category and that's how we
should describe them.
I don't think describing things,
oh,
you do drugs,
you know,
like this.
That's a dumb.
Well,
yeah,
of course I do.
What am I stupid.
They figured out how to do things that
are way better than not having them.
And there's plenty of drugs that are
excellent,
like the idea that you're going to be
completely drug free is dumb.
Our brains are a drug factory.
Yeah.
I don't do damaging drugs.
Don't do terrible drugs,
don't do meth,
don't do things that are going to fuck
you up.
Yeah.
Don't do the.
Yeah,
there's probably some stuff you should
avoid just because it's not healthy for
you.
But the problem is labeling them all
drugs.
It depends on the dose.
It depends on the context.
So that one of the,
the FDA made their reputation in the
early sixties on blocking thalidomide to
be prescribed in America for morning
sickness for pregnant women because it
caused all these solidimide babies.
Um,
and it was,
I'm skeptical woman who ended up winning
the president's Medal of honor,
the only person from the FDA for
blocking this drug to linemite.
It was the epitome of the bad drug.
But now it's used in the treatment of
cancer.
It's an approved medication.
Thalidomide is an approved.
Let medications.
They just one of those medications that
only affects a certain pages,
certain blood vessels.
And it can be useful in certain ways are
terrible.
So it,
you know,
it's not that there's good and bad
drugs,
it's not that things are good or bad in
themselves.
Like I don't think methamphetamine is a
bad,
you know,
there's mass for that.
Do you ever do it?
I've tried it.
What's it like?
Um,
I like tried it one time.
You cleaned your house,
should have that kind of energetic.
Um,
you know,
it wasn't that it was similar to
cocaine.
Um,
it was a stimulant that
can be really useful.
My father,
this was a shocking thing.
My father was a doctor,
a pediatrician and years ago,
and he's retired now,
but he,
he,
well after I was into doing psychedelics
and it dropped out with,
this was what I was focusing on.
He shared with me that he and his,
uh,
medical friends did math because they
were under these ridiculous residencies
and they had to work for these really
long hours.
Wow.
And that in the fifties it was very
common for residents,
medical doctors with all sorts of
people,
zoo,
methamphetamine to,
and,
and it's,
it was a major tool used in the war and
with the soldiers and it's um,
you know,
it doesn't have this,
um,
brain,
it doesn't have this evolutionary feel
in a way.
It helps you do,
you're doing,
but there's a way where psychedelics
help you refine what you're doing.
And so it just gives you energy.
Does it give you food?
There's a mood to.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's.
So mtma is methylenedioxy
methamphetamine,
so there is a similar molecular change
with other additions to it,
which fundamentally changed how it
happens,
what it does in the brain.
So that's a part of maybe what triggers
the euphoria as well as the dopamine
release.
Yeah.
That is so that,
that chemically,
that the army in 1952,
the chemical warfare and people,
they were looking for mind control
drugs.
And so they did a study with animal
toxicity studies looking for ld
[inaudible] and others with eight
different drugs in a range.
One of them was Mtma and one was,
it was like meth amphetamine to
masculine.
So mtma is kind of like I'm masculine in
a sense that it has that which is from
pod,
which has this psychedelic,
um,
ego dissolving and
things emerging and nonverbal processing
and emotional intensity that it has that
from masculine,
but it's not that eco desolving it's
more you're calmer and that has the
energy from methamphetamine but not in a
jittery way because you can sit still,
you can meditate,
meditators are now,
you know,
some of them have learned from Mtma or
Psilocybin to tip in a meditative
practice.
So you can use these in any number of,
of different ways.
And so you kind of have this paradoxical
combination of methamphetamine and
masculine that produced the molecule.
It does something different but
reminiscent.
And it is something that I believe that
will be used in initially highly
controlled therapeutic settings for
particular clinical indications.
And over time,
and by overtime,
I mean I'm 10 or 20 years,
there would be a,
uh,
a development of psychedelic clinics
like hospice centers.
Hospice centers spread all over America
in 30 years.
The first one was 1974,
2004.
There was 3,500,
so a place to help people who are at the
end of life,
so these are psychedelic treatment
centers to help people do ego death or
to to tie to their old selves or to see
more or that these centers will be
developed all over America.
I think over a process of once the drugs
are approved and probably Mtma and
silicide and we'll both be approved
around the same time.
I'm one of the other,
you know,
in 20,
21 is our current predictions and then
we'll start elaborating these clinics
and then people will get more and more
comfortable to it so that a
medicalization proceeds legalization and
that's what we've seen with medical
marijuana that the culture gets
comfortable through this process of I'm
now research and use that they can trust
that they see directly and they see
distribution centers that aren't violent
and people see a system and they then
are now.
Now it's.
The latest poll was 60 percent of
Americans in favor Americans in favor of
marijuana legalization.
Wow.
Highest it's ever been.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
so that,
I think that it's,
I think that we need,
people are under so much stress and if
you look around at the world,
the world is under so much stress and
the environment is under stress and the
cultures are bumping up against each
other,
that we need to have all the tools
available to manage the stress because
it's a,
it's a tremendously crucial time in
human history where we have these
capabilities through our technology that
we never have for impact.
Planetary Systems went away.
These psychedelic drugs that are kind of
technology as well.
There are technology to get us to
understand how our brains functioning.
Yes.
And there's,
there's this,
um,
a confluence of coincidence,
of timing that the,
um,
Albert Hoffman who invented lsd first
upgraded and 38 and then accidentally
ingested it in 43,
felt that the development of nuclear
splitting of the atom was occurring
contemporaneously with this discovery of
LSD.
And,
and in his view,
there was this kind of outer technology
and this inner technology.
And that Einstein said the splitting of
the atom has changed everything except
our motive thinking.
And hence we drift towards unparalleled
could astrophe what shall be required as
a substantially new mode of thinking.
And Albert Hoffman was like,
well,
I do wonder about the,
um,
the technology,
which many people think that if it comes
from nature,
it's really good.
You know,
they're there if it's plant medicine,
but if it comes from a lab at somehow
suspect.
But I think that it comes from our mind.
We're from nature labs,
so lsd nature of these plants,
they just extract the chemicals from
these plants.
When you break it down to what the
chemicals are,
you can reproduce those in the lab.
It's not as,
as.
It's not
natural.
It's exactly the same thing as natural.
It's all natural,
right?
Because it's all from something that's
on earth.
Well actually,
because we're trying to see,
you know,
how we're operating in the public
benefit manner and fair trade and all
this.
I asked the company that's now making us
are a kilogram of.
We're having a new kilogram of Mtma made
and if you need more.
I thought you said you had a gang of it.
We have 960 grams,
but it's,
it's not gmp medical.
It's not acceptable for phase three
research.
Oh yeah.
I would say that.
Something like that.
So I would say went bad.
We got to keep it away.
The kids.
Well we do.
We want to give it away to researchers.
So if there are researchers that are
listening,
we have free
time researching.
We would search for you too.
We would like to give it there,
but the uh,
mostly crocodile attacks.
But I'll fuck around with some ideas
about the current.
Alaina is costing us,
um,
to have the medical grade is now costing
us $400,000.
Zero.
Of course we need that.
We need that medical grade and that's
what our event.
You got to like a bucket of this stuff
laying around.
Well,
but it's not,
you know,
that's where we're making this
transition.
Yes.
Into the higher regulated areas.
So it is just that the standards of
procurement weren't as strict.
Is that?
Yes.
That the,
that the symphony may just as pure as
the,
what we're going to get,
by the way,
never used the word procurement.
One of those words that are used in the
smoothness of the right word is that
okay could use right there.
It's the pedigree of all the
ingredients,
so there has to be a paper trail for the
ingredients and so you don't have that
right now.
You've got your shift from a dealer.
We sort of.
One of the things that he didn't have
all of the paperwork.
Oh,
it's like a car.
Apparently there's a part of the process
of making mtma where you need aluminum
and took some aluminum.
Jesus Christ with Rowan forks in there
and he took some aluminum foil and use
that in the process.
Oh,
that's bad.
Well,
because it's not like witchy aluminum
foil and which batch and where did it
come from?
And Jesus Christ.
This guy through aluminum foil into your
fucking mixture.
Janky ass fucking way to make things.
Throw the metal in.
It seems so stupid.
I'm sure it was a really bad cans.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
I'm in it.
Want to roll?
We're rolling.
Yeah.
If I knew more chemistry,
I could kind of explain what it did and
in the process.
But aluminum is super calm,
a common rather aluminum is like a,
we think of aluminum as being frying
pans,
but that's not the,
that's not the form it takes in the
wild,
you know,
we're car panels and make a lot of cars
out of aluminum now because they figured
out how to make like super lightweight
but very strong aluminum.
That's as strong as steel but lighter.
But aluminum is everywhere.
It's in dirt.
Like it's like one of the most common
metals.
So they use this stuff.
How much do you need?
Like in say a tiny amount?
I don't think it was all that much.
I was.
What does it do?
I,
I don't.
I'm not a chemist so I can't really say.
He didn't get curious.
Have you found other shit you were
taking?
I was just like,
wow,
this is a peer Mtma great dude.
I would've been like,
hold the fuck up.
I'm just saying you threw a fork in
there to sit down and you gotta tell me
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Why does it have to have aluminum foil?
We went to the FDA and we said,
is there some way we can take this Mtma,
which is just as pure as what we're
going to get and turn it into medical
grade,
and they said there's no way you can
really do that because you have to.
This is now preparing for prescription
Mtma,
so I understand.
All right,
so I have to take it from every initial
ingredient has to be verified at the
source,
weighed out,
documented,
and then you make it and then it's
medical grade.
Well,
is that right?
More or less so.
Of this 400,000.
We're about $75,000 is just to validate
all the methods that are being used.
Another 54,000 is three years.
Stability Studies to show that the MTMA
can last three years.
Even though we have mtma from 1985,
we're still using this that we have
stability,
purity studies on throughout the years,
but it's about this particular batch and
actually our 30th anniversary
celebration on April 17th in Oakland at
the Scottish rite center.
It's just a plug for a party.
This is a plug for a party.
There you just snuck that in is for
raising money to illegal drug deal to
buy this Mtma.
How do people find out about this?
And they didn't get there.
Go to the maps,
that org website and there's information
right on the homepage.
Powerful.
Thank you.
And it's about helping people though
also think about having dinners in their
own homes with their friends.
So are you going to make a holiday dude?
Why not?
Man?
Columbus has a fucking holiday and he's
widely believed to be a piece of shit,
right?
Uh,
yes,
yes.
I think,
um,
well let's say Lummis is supposed to be
a piece of shit.
Okay.
Well,
I,
I think that once we get empty medicine,
medicine and then it becomes legal and
then those people are doing it in
Columbus,
then we can turn Columbus Day into mdm a
day.
It's a great idea.
Coming.
Look,
Columbus did start something in motion,
but Columbus as a person,
if you google them board,
it was a terrible human being.
He was a good role.
There was an account of one of the
missionaries,
I believe that was there on the island.
I think it was a Catholic missionary,
I forget what religion,
but anyway,
this one religious person,
um,
wrote this account of what Columbus and
his soldiers that did do some native
people and it was just horrific and you
realize these were the people that
everybody was worried about,
like we were talking about a boat shows
up and some monsters get off that boat
and these were the people and what they
had done to these for gold.
They found out at some of them had gold
and they just,
they just did a horrific shit.
Very similar to what like,
um,
happened on this coast here.
I'm with the INCAS,
you know,
the aztecs rather.
Yeah.
There's a story of Cabeza de Vaca.
Do you know that story?
Which stories?
Alvara Nunez.
Cabeza de Vaca.
This is the story,
a true story of people that found real
gold,
a Spanish conquistadores this,
this is,
um,
it's been made into a movie.
It should be made into a more major
movie.
What's that movie called?
Um,
children of the sun children,
the son Jimmy.
It was,
um,
I think that's what I think the movie
should be called.
I'm not sure if it was that.
You just make up your own names.
I like star wars,
Bro.
Well,
like big foot and his buddy in space.
the story that out.
I've written that actually this,
this is incredible.
This is the hidden history of America.
This is the first medium children of the
sun is the script I've written actually
doing man.
You smoked too much pot before the show.
Be honest with us a little bit.
That's a little bit,
a little bit.
That's a fault of us.
Did a little bit right?
Yeah.
It's good for creative brainstorming
and,
and so the,
and the movie the story.
We'll just move you that you can watch
though.
I think it's,
it might be Cabeza de Vaca.
Uh,
it's got a dwarf Sharman that doesn't
really exist in the real story and it's,
I think this has to be to hold true
because it's the hope of America.
It's the hope.
It's a story of a several hundred
conquistadores around 15,
28 trying to link up with Cortez blown
off course in a hurricane land in around
Tampa,
Florida,
and have this bunch of hundreds of these
conquistadores.
Only four of them survive and they
eventually,
one of them is black,
one of them is a more a slave.
The rest are white and they become
slave.
So they start out at the head of the
empire exploring and plundering,
and then they get destroyed.
They become slaves.
So they get captured.
They get captured.
Native Americans that lived in Florida.
Yeah.
So the native Americans that lived in
Florida,
the seminole tribe,
right?
Is that them?
I'm not sure which.
They,
they,
they ended up running away and it takes
eight years.
This whole process that they go through
the.
This is the charting.
So this is the first meeting of the
black,
white and red races in much of North
America.
Wow.
And at one point when they're slaves to
get some use from them,
the Indians,
the native Americans say they want them
to do some healings.
They think they're special.
They're there is a black person,
they came and they say,
we're not healers,
we don't,
you know,
and they say if you don't do it,
we're going to not feed you.
And they try to do a healing and it
actually works.
The person says they're better.
So what exists is,
uh,
the document,
there's a lot of historical documents,
but the point was the ailment that they
documented adapt to,
I don't know what it was they do talk
about.
Um,
but you wrote a script on it.
Well,
I don't remember the exact first.
This was a long time.
I decided that at some point I couldn't
try to make the movie happen and also
try to make Mtma happen
aside for a long time,
but it's the,
the,
the symbol I have set aside,
but I haven't even thought about for a
long time.
But I think that the story is important
for people to hear it.
Alvara Nunez,
Cabeza de Vaca,
they became healers and they went
eventually.
All they didn't.
People gave them all their stuff.
They didn't want it.
They just want it to go to where the,
um,
where they thought what Cortez was,
yeah,
but hold on.
How did they become healers?
Just because they heal this one guy that
they just said,
fuck,
this is our new job.
It seemed obviously I didn't know I was
magic.
Yes,
they,
they were like,
they were pressed into service as
healers and some of them they felt were
particularly more talented than others
at it and they ended up with basically
that the whole groups of Indians that
would,
one tribe would take them to the next
tribe.
They had the allegiance of all of these
Indians and they learned to live very
humbly.
They didn't take stuff for themselves.
They were incredibly good survivors
through amazing hardships and they saw
their humanity with the Indians and they
had sort of conquered through love
through these healings.
And then they ended up getting to where
the west was to,
to where Cortez,
I mean we're the key stores where they
finally saw burned out villages and
people as slaves and they were taken,
captured themselves.
And Alberto Nunez,
Cabeza de Vaca went and was taken as
prisoner back and he had to write this
report to the king about what happened
to the expedition and the black men,
Esteban,
Nico,
he stayed and he traveled up and
explored a lot of California and ended
up being killed by the natives.
But the story Henry Miller wrote a
tremendous introduction to this story
about the salvation of,
uh,
the westward expansion,
the opportunity.
What it showed is that through this
respect,
through whatever circumstances they got,
they,
through cooperation and nonviolence,
they had the support they had.
And then,
well,
the four that they didn't kill the four
that they.
Yes,
96 that they killed.
They didn't get the.
Yeah,
yeah.
Took them is not in violence thing.
Only worked out when it got done.
Like four people.
That's not a good strategy.
I would say that's 96 percent
ineffective.
Fucking terrible idea.
Violence work.
These four guys live to become fucking
wacky.
Carnival healers.
I,
if you have tons of amazing look at this
story of,
um,
this report.
And then he recommended a book on
subject.
Yeah,
there is.
Um,
there's the actual original document
that Cubby Cabeza de Vaca,
Elvar Nunez,
Cabeza de Vaca,
the marvelous adventures of Cabeza de
Vaca,
I think as the translation of it.
COUPA.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
Ken Burns documentary on him called the
West,
I believe is what I was looking at.
Ken Burns did something on him.
Ken Burns do something on the web.
The wild west.
Wasn't that a different,
is that he did it on this guy.
This is the Ken Burns in it though.
It's a part of it.
Oh,
I see.
Story first appeared that kitten burdens
the West pbs documentary that first
aired in 1996.
Wow.
Yeah.
And this has been an opera about it.
There's also a lot of people have sort
of looked at this story and taken a lot
of hope from it that um,
even though it took a lot of death for
these people to get to this attitude
and,
and the Indians were,
you know,
keeping slaves and killing each other,
but they were able to,
um,
have a,
a different kind of.
They got off the boat as those,
you know,
rampaging people,
but,
but they transformed into um,
humanists and humble and actually Cabeza
de Vaca was able to go on a second
expedition to South America.
He was able to talk his way into it and
he did it.
He explored more areas than other people
did without killing any Indians.
And he discovered the request,
who falls where the movie,
the mission was made big waterfalls.
And so he,
he started demonstrated that he was a
good ambassador between cultures and
tried to still,
you know,
explore,
exploit,
but,
but do it in a way of,
uh,
a little bit more collaboration.
That's really interesting.
It's really interesting to think of
cultures colliding like that.
Some crazy people from Spain getting in
a boat,
getting washed out of their course and
landing in Florida,
climbing all,
trying to figure out what the hell's
going on,
getting attacked,
attacking people being at war.
And then four dudes make it through that
and live.
Imagine how cool those guys must have
been like talking to them.
Yeah,
native American society.
You're so cool.
When I going to kill you,
man.
They,
they became traders for awhile before
they kind of trade d.
yeah.
Triggers.
Yes.
Traders.
And they could,
you know,
they got very hardy and our would.
Um.
How long did they live?
Some of them.
Well,
this,
the,
Nico ended up getting killed.
He stayed in Mexico.
He didn't want to go back to be a slave
and then he went with the Christian
missionaries up into California and then
got killed in California.
Yeah.
By native Americans here by native
Americans here.
Um,
some of the other native Americans need
a better name.
They do.
It's clumsy.
Native American saying native Americans
clumsy.
Saying Indian is even more clumsy.
I like a first nation that's like with
the Canadians use.
I liked that first nations.
That's,
that's their real claim right there.
First nation because the bottom line is
as far as we know their first nation,
but we don't,
you know.
Well,
we did a study in Canada with first
nations people who were suffering from
addiction because their,
their culture has been under such
attack,
but it was,
I'm Peruvian Third World Peruvian
shamans bringing Iowasca to work with
first nations people who were addicted
with,
uh,
Dr Gobler Montay,
Western psychiatrist.
It's kind of,
that guy's amazing.
He is mediating this
excession run by and then we were able
to,
um,
support the team that did some outcome
measures and suggested that,
that this,
um,
third world,
first world,
first nations people that these w,
it's cultural bumping into each other
all over now more ever than before in
the history of the world.
Probably.
He's that cultural appropriation or.
No,
I think it's appropriation.
If,
um,
if you don't,
if you steal,
you can tend to be a native American and
hold your own pod ceremonies,
the that and on,
and red paint.
I think the,
the flattery,
imitation is the most sincere form of
flattery.
So I think it's like you want people to
adopt if you think it's good,
but they don't have to adapt your dogma
or your rituals.
I mean,
I see that with our mdms,
we have our method and we have it.
Everything is videotaped.
We even have it scored.
We have raiders that look at the
therapist and score them on how much
they're implying that we're hearing with
our method,
but we want other people with other
methods to use it and
see how it works in other contexts.
Native Americans have their own rules,
right.
When they have in their territories,
they can.
That's why they can put casinos up in
there as do they have rules as far as
psychedelic drugs,
they have their own rules.
Well,
they have because on tribal lands,
right?
Well first off they have authority and
tribal lands,
but a lot of people work in the military
or do stuff with the federal government,
so they have the religious freedom to
practice.
The native American church is the US
Supreme Court upheld and a congress that
they can,
but the federal government actually
tried to limit it so that if you had to
have 25 percent Indian blood to be part
of the native American church in order
to participate in the pod rituals,
the states don't have that kind of
racial requirement,
but to try to prevent the spread of this
religion from the native Americans to
wider groups of hippies and others that
like pod,
you know,
they tried to make a racial.
The federal government does have this
racial limit,
but it's largely ignored and it's
ignored by the states.
That's why white dudes were trying to be
Rastafarians.
Remember that?
That's where white dirty,
stinky people with dreadlocks came from.
That's how it was reignited
that we're all fans of Bob Marley.
Right?
That's why they.
I knew a dude who was a pot dealer and
he claimed Rastafari and he said,
this is part of my religion,
man.
It was like real serious.
Right?
In those cases,
they've lost in court or they have,
but they didn't lose the.
What is it?
Assented to die.
May,
what is the church,
he said the son to die mate went up to
the ninth circuit.
It didn't go to the Supreme Court,
but the,
when y'all do vegetal,
I just came from Santa Fe this morning
and that's where the lead church,
the y'all hall was located in Santa Fe
and it was Jeffrey Bronfman from the
Canadian Jewish Bronfman family from
Seagram's fortune,
from smuggling alcohol during
prohibition,
and then building this massive business
as one of the grandkids.
He ended up becoming appreciative of
IOWASCA.
And so he hired the best lawyers and
worked on this case that they won a
unanimous supreme court case affirming
the vegetal,
the Union of the plants.
It's,
it's two different plants,
roots and
vines and leaves and um,
you put it together so to the union hall
were um,
and they have legal protection in the
United States.
On the other hand,
it's,
you know,
it's a church.
Um,
I went to it and I was hearing I,
I really enjoyed.
I went to it twice and the second time
it was like,
here's the myth of our church,
the myth of the or the origin myth.
And part of it was that King Solomon
went to the Amazon and told them how to
put these plants together.
Right.
And I'm like,
King Solomon.
And so there's,
it's just,
it is a religion.
Right?
So I think that,
um,
well that's why,
that's why the Supreme Court agreed with
it because it's so wacky.
Like,
yeah,
you guys sound like a religion,
right?
I mean,
but it's happening.
So they know that they didn't make it
up.
I will ask,
uh,
having an incredible effect in America.
It's really amazing.
The number of different people that are
using it,
not necessarily in these exact religious
context,
but in kind of shamanistic or personal
growth or more or,
or kind of little modified or,
or even in these services.
Why hasn't that religion expanded?
Well,
it's,
um,
it,
it's being used quite a lot.
There's a lot of ceremonies in
California,
all over America,
all over the world with Iowasca.
It's just,
but this union to vegetal udv that.
But they have,
they're expanding somewhat,
but there,
it's,
how do they have authority?
They have authority.
They have legal authority from the US
Supreme Court.
They're the only ones,
the Santa diamond went up to the ninth
circuit.
So they essentially have the same
argument that the,
it just didn't get appealed
to the Supreme Court by the prosecutor.
So that the new united,
the vegetal I didn't say you.
Now when the owl hoo and yell,
when do vegetal they do have that.
So they're locked down.
They are,
yes.
And sends a dime.
He is too.
But as I said,
if they want in the appeals court and
when you got to get Richard Branson,
you got to get Richard Branson evolved
and start opening these bitches up like
right next to virgin records,
leverage records anymore.
Why haven't they expanded more?
And part of it is,
you know,
how,
um,
cultural integration,
so cultural appropriation,
but cultural integration,
so they're bringing a tradition from a
different culture,
um,
and they're trying to integrate it at a
rate where it doesn't,
it grows,
it's constitutionally protected,
but it doesn't grow too fast.
Maybe there's a way where it could grow
too fast and there wouldn't be the care
and the use of the tea and they want to
make sure that it's responsibly handled.
These are the people that are running
your church.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Jeffrey Brockman and they're just too
busy getting high.
They want to keep it on the DL.
No,
no,
no.
They out and lay on the floor.
Well,
you know,
you don't hide by going to the Supreme
Court,
obviously.
Yeah,
but I think it's amazing that they did
actually get the ruling.
I mean,
that's amazing that they're taking one
of the most potent psychedelic drugs
known to man.
It's true and.
But they got the support of mainstream
religions because there's a lot of weird
things that mainstream religions do for
cultural practices or even hasn't a
precedent been set with wine?
Yeah.
It's most certainly a drug and it can be
used by children in certain ritual
ceremonies and it can,
but it's a common part of Catholicism,
like wind is a,
is a very common part.
There's a lot of weird stuff in religion
and as soon as you start saying that one
person can't do their weeds,
weird stuff,
they go,
okay,
well what kind of weird stuff do you get
exemptions for?
And you look at their exemptions.
You're like,
well,
what?
You can cut baby Dick's.
What are you doing?
You're rubbing dirt on your forehead on
Wednesday.
Will you guys,
what the fuck are you doing in the idea
that one could make fun of the other
assist at a certain point in time.
So you guys have blinders on.
Okay.
This whole thing is pretty wacky.
The Union Union vegetable,
they might have the right idea.
That might be the only way to do it.
Well,
the part about that that's really good
is that while they have their dog man
and their their traditions,
it's about the experience.
It's about the individual experience for
yourself.
Rick strassman did it with them and he
told me it was very strange.
He said it's really strong,
really strong IOWASCA,
and they sing songs about Jesus.
Well Daddy,
what that like?
Yeah,
it's a trip.
Yeah.
I think you'd have to have a generous
spirit in a way like,
okay,
it's Jesus,
but you know it's about reverence and
you kind of generalize and you're
thinking about this the other day,
and tell me if this makes any sense to
you.
If you have this idea when you go like
when you take.
I've never done Iowasca,
but I've done dmt on multiple occasions,
right?
So I've had this psychedelic effect,
the most potent version of that.
Right?
I would wonder if you went in with the
intention and had these experiences with
the intention to communicate with some
benevolent deity that you believe is
responsible for all life and all love on
the planet.
If you kept thinking of that as you
entered into this dimethyltryptamine
state of consciousness,
isn't it possible that a vast majority
of what is happening when you are having
a psychedelic trip is the word
hallucination?
It's very strange because with the
hallucination implies is in this world,
but we're sitting right here with tables
and chairs and rooms.
Something could.
You could see it,
but it could not be real.
The problem with that is like what are
you seeing and why can't other people?
Can other people see it too?
Well,
if other people could see it,
then it's not a hallucination.
Right,
so it's how do you know what other
people are saying,
we really don't right now.
How do you know when you close your
eyes,
you're on a psychedelic drug.
How much of what you're experiencing is
your visual cortex interacting with your
mind,
interacting with these drugs and your
your creativity and your consciousness
are colliding and gliding and dancing
together along with your imagination and
in the hold on a second and in this
moment,
if you go into that with his intention,
your imagination can conjure up this
Jesus type character in the IOWASCA
ceremony and he can be real and he can
be what you want him to be and he could
be a manifestation of your own
experiences in this life that you've
carried around as memories and carried
around as emotions and that in this
psychedelic state.
If you continually go to it with that
intention,
it's entirely possible that they do
experience something like that.
Exactly.
I think that you,
we see through our own filters and we
see a lot of times what we want to see
and that we can coalesce a lot of
feelings and images that are pre verbal
into certain kinds of symbols.
Well,
especially if you're on it and insanely
potent psychedelic drug.
Yeah,
so the idea that we ever know the
ultimate truth that it's not somehow or
other filter through our preconceptions.
I'm John Lilly wrote this great book.
One of the things he did,
I thought it was great.
It was called simulations of God and
it's like different conceptions that
people have of God and how you get to
these views and then there's a way to
transcend that and see something even
deeper and deeper and that,
that we have these filters and so the
culture is.
And the context is more important than
the drug.
So I think one of the issues of the
sixties was people had so much faith
that they
wanted so much cultural change.
They were so.
It was such a strife filled time that
they had this hope,
this unreasonable hope that the drugs
were enough.
That the psychedelics were enough that
they would somehow or other bring this
connection to the truth to to this new
understanding just by themselves and
it's really more about the context,
but the context and with a proper open
context and in our case a therapeutic
context in the experimental sense.
Then when you add the pharmacology,
it produces really unusual opportunities
to go very deep and that's what I think
we can show that we can do that and
contain it in a regulatory therapeutic
healing context that can slowly be
accepted by a our culture and that
that's really the of the value
proposition that we're presenting to the
FDA.
The way you described it as why maps are
so important,
because I'm talking about making Jesus
exists when you're tripping balls,
I'm making your own.
Jesus like while you're tripping and you
bring it back to studies and science and
data and presented the paper.
I'm wearing a tie.
Okay.
And so for us,
yes,
yes.
We're actually discussing should I wear
a tie at the 30th better or or not,
but what are you going to do a.
I haven't decided yet.
I just dress like Jimi Hendrix,
but,
but the date that the data is really
this,
I'm double checking of what we think is
true.
Right?
And it's a way where we have to have
that humility that we don't necessarily
know this ultimate truth,
but there's no way to know.
And that's not just humility,
that's just a fact.
There's no way to know what you're
experiencing with anybody else's
experiencing when they're tripping.
You really don't know.
We don't know what it is.
And it's entirely possible that it's
something that we don't understand yet.
Yeah.
And so,
so the reason I brought it back in a way
to the science is that we're
operationalizing its effect on symptoms.
So whether you have this memory that is
actually true.
So whether it's Jesus or whether you're
remembering childhood sexual abuse,
whether that.
I don't like how you tied the two of
those together.
I was right about the Catholic church.
There was a little stop.
A few things I leaped over there,
but,
but whether that occurred in actuality
is an important question for the legal
system more for other ways,
but from a therapeutic,
from healing,
from a compassionate point of view,
if this expression,
if it's symbolic or actual,
if it has the consequence of helping
people come to terms with themselves and
to get more acceptance about what
happened.
That's what we're looking at.
We're looking at the outcomes.
So I think that that's the practical
part.
That's the science part.
It's like there are questions.
Um,
I,
I believe I,
for a lot of times in my early lsd
trips,
I wanted God to show up and I wanted the
truth.
How arrogant is not busy.
Yeah.
God doesn't have a lot of other shit
going on.
I remember from my bar where I was like,
the very next day,
Barb Mitzvah,
what the fuck?
God,
you know,
I studied all this Hebrew,
so in my bed the next day after my
birthday.
So I was like,
I was the same.
I mean,
like I'm not a man.
I'm not any different than there was.
And I,
I,
I couldn't,
uh,
took me a couple of days where I thought
God was maybe busy,
maybe a lot of people got bar Mitzvah'd
that day and after like a week I
recognize,
you know,
I'm not going to change and it's going
to take something else.
The ritual didn't quite do it.
And then even with my lsd trips,
wanting to see God wanting to have this
clarity and not quite getting it,
and then appreciating that,
that that was a delusion in some ways
that keeping the uncertainty is keeping
integrity.
And,
and um,
but there's that strong longing for that
for certainty.
You're sounding like a dude who's
rationalizing that he didn't get to meet
God.
He's upset.
God didn't show up.
The whole thing will be different,
right?
Because it's like aliens and visit
everybody when he does visit.
It's a very unique experience and it's
real.
I don't know,
man.
I think there's real problem in saying,
you know,
what other people experience,
whether it's under the influence of
psychedelic drugs or whether it's
completely sober or whether it's been in
a meditative state.
The idea that anybody can tell you what
you experienced or what you got out of
something is foolish,
so then it becomes a matter of whether
or not we're protecting people,
so if our laws are designed to protect
people,
we should do it scientifically.
We should look across the board at all
the damaging things and we don't do that
at all.
That's why the government never
discusses cigarettes because we all know
how many people cigarettes kill every
year.
It's in the hundreds of thousands and no
one brings it up.
No one running for president,
no one running for Congress.
They just don't bring it up.
It's not something they want to fight
against because if they do,
they'll get slaughtered with money.
So it's not about whether or not they're
trying to protect us.
So then what is it about,
although at the same time,
cigarette use has been going down a
little.
It's still half a million people die
every year in this country.
It's still.
Yeah,
it's still.
It's crazy.
If it was just 5,000 people in pot,
how quick would they shut it down?
If 5,000 people died prematurely?
Every year because of marijuana,
how quick would it be?
The Demon of television?
It depends on what we do,
about the benefit side of the equation.
It's not.
Nobody doesn't exist though.
Hold the unit.
You see what I'm saying?
Like 35,000 isn't dying.
Right?
But if it was the 500,000 or diving from
cigarettes are extremely significant,
right?
Well what should be done,
but we should do is make everything
legal and then let people figure out
what you want to do and not want to do
this,
which is what we do with most things
today,
right?
Most things like cigarettes and alcohol
that can kill you.
We let you try.
Exactly because no one should be able to
tell you what to do.
Man,
if you want to Charles boot Koski it and
just drink and smoke yourself to an
early grave and just
scribble the coolest shit along the way.
Who gives a fuck?
It's all finite,
right?
Who's one person tell another person
that they can't be Amex,
jump or skydive?
Well,
I think you're going to have that.
I want you to be free.
I want to be free to do what I feel I
should do.
You should have the same freedom,
but if you are hurting yourself,
I am compassionate and let's try to see
are you struggling with your own trauma
or what?
But,
but not to try to,
um,
what,
what do you do about rock climbers and
yeah,
you're just trying to get safe
equipment.
Either run with bad childhoods.
He cut them off,
you know,
um,
people can make choices about risk in
different ways and I think you really,
at some point,
you know,
where does it shade into suicide and.
Well,
I do think suicide should be illegal.
There's another one.
Well,
I think the,
um,
I think there should be.
I mean,
the,
I don't think you should be punished if
you tried to get committed suicide and
you survived then fuck right.
I don't think he need that America
because I think it should be against the
law and I think this is suicide when
people are end of life and pain.
It makes sense to me certainly,
but there has to be a lot of
protections.
But I think there is this general
feeling like life is a gift that I have
and that that somehow we need to run its
course rather than,
well,
I think this is another way we're mtma
therapy will help.
And I think that there's a lot of people
that are haunted by their memories,
memories of their past,
memories of their own failures,
ma'am.
Memories of things that they did wrong.
And those things can really fuck with
you.
You know,
people define themselves in this weird
way like by their past failures like
that is.
That's all the experience they have.
That's all they know of themselves.
And they,
it,
they.
People have a very difficult time just
saying,
okay,
well those things are things that I'll
never do again.
I made these mistakes and now I'm this
person who's learned.
And that's a really hard jump for some
people because they need some sort of a
memory definition of their patterns of
behavior and when the memory definition,
when they look in their own memory and
everything is just failures and coming
up short and Mr Ren and car got
repossessed.
Those kinds of failures over and over
and over again stack up and you define
yourself by those failures and it
becomes really hard to move forward
because it's really hard for people and
so each little positive step that people
can do can be so significant because it
alters the course,
not just all like there was this Tony
Robbins thing once.
I hate them,
quote Tony Robbins.
It's got some really good quotes,
but one of the things he was talking
about was how it was just incremental
changes in your life.
So if you have two cars that are going
or two boats that are going in this
direction and one veers off course,
just five degrees.
Well if they both go 10 miles,
this one goes further and further and
further from the other one and it keeps
going further.
It's going,
it's it.
The course.
It changes the direction and MDM a
therapy or any sort of a psychedelic
experience that's boundary dissolving
and an ego dissolving and it just gets
to the raw heart of the matter and
allows you this really intense
perspective on it that's almost
unattainable.
Without those experiences.
Then that person leaves that and they
have almost like a fresh start in a
fresh understanding of who they are.
They self defined differently and that
in itself is like a recipe for success.
Yeah.
There's this beautiful part of accepting
oneself and loving oneself.
Even with all of these failures.
Even with everything that's happened,
it's not that you deny that it happened
or you don't see it.
It's just this sense that you can relax
and feel that self love and that is
what's so rare and I think that's why
Mtma is one of the most popular illegal
drugs in the world and why it needs and
will become a madison and the reason
that I selected it is also because
training therapists reaching to the
mainstream so that when we talk about
how do we incorporate this as a madison,
it's with healers.
It's with doctors and therapists and I
think what we found is that we have FDA
permission for a study where we can
administer it to therapists and part of
our training program,
we're studying the psychological effects
of Mtma taken by healthy volunteers in a
therapeutic setting.
Wow.
And it's a double blind crossover,
placebo controlled study,
but we can bring in therapists from all
over the world and give them an MMA
session where they are the patient and
they're seeing our method of how to
deliver it.
And so Mtma is something that I think
will have a smoother,
easier way into psychiatry and into
psychotherapy because of it so gentle
because it isn't so much ego dissolving
as ego.
Clarifying your defenses are relaxed and
you can kind of accept yourself for who
you are so you can see more clearly and
then how you integrate that and how you
make it so that that affects your daily
life
afterwards.
I think it's really important.
You were saying about it being a magical
experience,
so one of the most manageable
experiences or all the psychedelics
because it feels really good.
Yeah.
It's not like you're going to have a bad
trip for the most part.
Although some of the veterans have said,
you know,
I don't know why they call this ecstasy.
Why do you say that?
Because they're going through this
trauma from their war.
So it's,
it's so even under the experience of
Mtma or under the influence of Mtma it
still,
they didn't like the fact that it was
bringing back those memories?
No,
no,
they liked it because that was her,
this healing.
But it was painful.
Sometimes it makes the pain bearable.
It doesn't make the pain go away or it
doesn't change your memory.
Like it didn't happen.
Well I suppose someone had board so you
really can't imagine what their
experiences are.
It
could be even worse,
you know,
childhood sexual abuse and you can't
trust your parents or you can't trust
your circumstances are.
Yeah.
It's all terrible.
Terrible.
Yeah.
And how people can get into these
patterns.
It's awful.
And,
and it seems like,
um,
through the technical Mtma is part of
the technologies appealing that it's one
of the things that we were talking about
with Jamie before this podcast started.
Before you got here,
we were saying how ridiculous it is that
it takes so long to get things passed
and that the government,
the dea is going to review marijuana in
July.
Well they have this thing in July.
Yeah.
Well,
they're going to say no and we've been
working to explain what they're gonna
say no to.
I believe that the request is that
marijuana be rescheduled from schedule
one to schedule two.
Um,
and that,
this rescheduling the framework,
if you don't mind,
could you explain what the difference
between scheduled ones because we're too
far from the point of view.
So the schedule one is the worst drugs
and they have no medicinal value,
no medicinal value.
There are no current,
they're not currently accepted medical
and there's no currently accepted safety
under medical supervision and no
currently accepted medical use and high
potential for abuse scheduled two drug
and these are the most heavily
criminalized drugs scheduled to except
for certain exceptions in schedule two,
which are also drugs with a high abuse
potential,
but have an accepted medical use like
methamphetamine and cocaine and cocaine
and heroin and heroin is not in the u s
but opiates,
all the opiates or heroin is illegal in
England,
but it's been blocked here.
So.
But oxycontin's are scheduled who every
medicine that you can get and scheduled
chats essentially the same as heroin.
Right?
Isn't it?
It's very sometimes more dangerous in
certain ways.
The psych psych,
it's a synthetic.
It has very similar.
Yes.
Affects.
Yeah,
but it has medical use for pain,
so moving from schedule one for
scheduled too.
There's been efforts to try to force the
dea to do this,
but the way the schedules are set up,
there has to be a currently accepted
medical use and the data is not there.
And you.
You talked before about you know,
when do you have enough anecdotal data
or.
I believe that we are so capable of
fooling ourselves into believing what we
want to believe and to seeing Jesus when
Jesus might not be there,
that we need science.
We should take marijuana through the
drug development system and we should
take the psychedelics.
It doesn't need to.
We were about to start a study with
marijuana.
I basically started trying to do drug
development research with marijuana in
1992.
This is the first time in 2016,
but since there's no established medical
benefits of marijuana that had been
proven in any scientific way.
Yes,
there's been a lot of evidence in phase
two pilot studies,
but the definition of real proof is
phase three studies these large scale
studies that you work and negotiate with
Fda for the marijuana plant.
Now gw pharmaceuticals is a company in
England that grows marijuana,
it takes extracts,
sativex it's a teaching and cbd
combination and a pill.
And then they also have epidiolex which
is cbd for childhood epilepsy.
So they are in phase three studies.
So there are people working with
marijuana extracts in different
nonsmoking delivery systems going
through the system.
But the plant itself is highly
effective.
It doesn't cause lung cancer if you
smoke it,
if you vaporize it,
um,
it's even less irritating to lungs.
And there's the possibility that a low
cost plant in Israel right now,
they grow high potency trimmed buds for
fifty cents a gram,
$14 an ounce.
So I think there's public benefit in
making the marijuana plant in smoked or
vaporized form into a madison available
paid for by insurance as a alternative
to all these other medicines.
But there is no effort right now.
We're starting it.
Six years ago we started a study for
marijuana for ptsd and veterans,
so we've talked about Mtma and the idea
is to help people with a few MTMA
sessions,
not need Mtma,
not need drugs,
sort of reorganize their brain,
but there's a lot of people with ptsd
that find marijuana to be helpful if
they don't have the nightmares,
they're more present focused and they're
thinking,
well maybe I don't want to do this Mtma
or maybe it's a supplement.
So there's never been a study of
marijuana for PTSD.
There's been a lots and lots of
anecdotal reports,
hundreds,
you know,
thousands of people saying that it's
helpful in different ways,
but marijuana is a palliative meaning
that it just treats the symptoms and
it's used usually everyday.
So it's taken us six years.
We're about to start the study and it
will take us another several years to
finish it.
I'm part of it will be at Johns Hopkins,
part of it will be an Arizona at 76
veterans with chronic treatment
resistant ptsd and retesting one sample
that's high thc,
one that's high cbd,
one that's kind of thc cbd combination.
And then one placebo and we've got a two
point $1,000,000 grant from the state of
Colorado,
Colorado to do this study and it's going
to be a definitive thing.
And because again,
we're nonprofit,
we're giving away the protocol,
there's no intellectual property like
that.
And so there's a for profit company,
private privateer that actually has
bought them early brand and they have a
medical marijuana company,
venture capital and they have um,
hustle,
Arius Tilray,
which is a big production of marijuana
production factory in British Columbia.
Supplies like 5,000 patients.
They're owned by private tier and we've
given them our marijuana protocol and so
they're going to use the study with our
study,
does with the same study design but with
their marijuana and they're going to
vaporize and they're going to,
we're going to smoke.
And then there's a new study starting in
Australia.
There's this guy who's grandchild had
pediatric epilepsy and nothing helped.
And then they tried to cbd and it
stopped the epileptic seizures to a
great extent.
And then the father donated 33 million
to the University of Sydney for cannabis
research.
It's the largest grant in the history of
the University of Sydney,
so they're going to take our protocol
and they're going to get marijuana from
tilray but put into capsules as edibles.
So we're going to have three different
studies,
um,
similar in design,
but smoked,
vaporized and edibles.
We're going to combine the data and so
this is the scientific process,
but it'll take us.
It's taken us six years so far just to
get the study,
even started the study will be three
years,
then we'll learn from it and we'd
probably need to do another three,
four years,
study a phase three because this is just
phase two.
And in the meantime we have to break the
government monopoly on marijuana because
in the US we're stuck with the
government marijuana and explain that.
Well,
the police in 1968,
andy while actually at Harvard wanted to
do study with marijuana.
And so the federal government started
with farm at the University of
Mississippi to grow marijuana for
research.
And ever since then the National
Institute of Drug Abuse has contracts
now.
And so the University of Mississippi,
a professor,
I'll solely.
It is now in charge,
they're the only federally licensed dea
licensed marijuana in America and the
FDA is a federal agency so it can only
work with drugs that are federally
legal.
So the only source of marijuana in
America that can be used in clinical
research is this marijuana controlled by
the nationalist on drug abuse,
which has been anti marijuana with this
contract with the University of
Mississippi.
And we have tried maps as tried starting
in 2000 to break this monopoly and we
submitted a application in 2001 with
Professor Lyle craker at Umass amherst.
And we won a dea administrative law
judge lawsuit the second time I've sued
the dea in one,
but in the end they ignore the judges.
They ignore the science and the politics
takes over and so,
and we lost in the appeals court in
2013.
So the way I described that,
we have this 960 grams of super pure
Mtma,
but it's not the appeal.
The government.
What did they say when they were
appealing?
They said that,
um,
that the government had an adequate
supply.
What does that mean for everybody in all
research or the research?
Yeah.
We show that they didn't have what we
needed and also meaning that the,
um,
there has to be an adequate and
uninterrupted did supply produced under
adequately competitive conditions?
Well,
also did you factor in the fact of the
different strains have different
responses?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's why we're using these,
you know,
different,
right.
But the government,
did they,
do,
they understand that there's different
strains are associated with different
feelings.
Only recently have they had any CBD
available.
So gw pharmaceuticals started in 1998.
Combining saddleback's was thc and CBD.
It was up until just last year that they
had the US government could provide
marijuana with cbd in it.
They've not been focused on making these
things into medicines.
It's more low potency research into the
risks of marijuana and it's the final
next step in the medical marijuana story
is to end the obstruction on privately
funded drug development research,
trying to make the plant into a madison.
And that's what I'm,
ironically,
it's easier to do research with
psychedelics than with marijuana to try
to make it into a madison because we
control our drug.
So I'm getting a,
a GMP Mtma I,
it's the same stuff we're going to use
in phase three that we want to market.
But the federal government,
marijuana can only be used in research.
It can't be marketed and because the
strains are all so different,
we can't show marijuana helps for ptsd
with one strain and then just say,
oh,
give us approval for any other strain.
Right?
So we need to use this.
And this is the true for FDA,
for other botanicals.
If you're going to do a study in
botanical medicines,
those phase three study needs to be with
the same,
uh,
consistent batch that you want to
market.
Well,
I guess this is all important because we
want the same sort of stringent process
to be taking place for a drug safer
arthritis or something like that.
Like there's so many drugs that have
been gone through clinical trials and
wind up still,
even after all that being dangerous.
But the problem with this is that we
know it's not dangerous.
It's not like there's any question
whatsoever about whether or not it's
hurting anybody.
Yes,
and what I'm basically saying is about
insurance and a science so that it
should be.
What I'm saying is marijuana should be
legal right away.
Of course people should be able to get
this.
The process that we're trying to go
through with making the marijuana plant
into a medicine is solving the
fundamental issue that all of these
medical marijuana states that have
approved medical marijuana laws,
the patients have to buy the medicine
themselves.
They don't get it covered by insurance.
That'll only happen when you go through
the FDA and you've made it federally
legal.
So the intention is to make it so that
people can get their medicine so that
they can get it paid for by insurance.
Is that the intention?
Yeah,
it's like a medicine,
right?
I mean,
and so the way to do that is to make it
federally illegal.
That's the best pathway you think the
federal legalization.
Well,
I think by I'm talking about fairly
legalized for medicine,
so to go through the FDA process then
insurance companies,
I mean they couldn't be doing studies
now and look at the fact that people are
using marijuana instead of a lot of more
expensive pharmaceutical medications and
that from an insurance company point of
view,
it could be wise to subsidize marijuana
right now it just hasn't happened yet.
As far as I'm aware that insurance
companies in Canada,
the Canadian government pays for medical
marijuana for veterans,
CSD.
The Canadian government pays for that.
Even though there's been no science are
these studies that are.
These three studies will be the first on
marijuana for Ptsd controlled studies
and so there's the likelihood that once
we make it into an FDA approved
medicine,
insurance companies will then be
willing,
now it's federally legal to cover it as
a medicine for what has been proved to
be particularly if it saves them money
on other medicines.
So that's the cultural.
Of course.
Then the pharmaceutical drug companies
are gonna.
There's gonna be a bounce back there.
It's all really.
The only thing that's holding us back is
this nutty system that we have right now
that's so complicated to make something
as harmless as marijuana become legal.
Well,
well the system has been blocked.
The system itself,
when it's unblocked,
isn't really that long.
You just talked about how okay,
civil war wasn't that long with with
psychedelics.
I mean part of it is also resources.
Do we have the resources to fund the
studies,
but in 1992,
the FDA had an advisory committee
meeting that was about what to do about
medical marijuana and what to do about
psychedelics and should they be
permitted to be studied as medicines.
This was in 1992 the,
so there'd been roughly 20 years of
suppression of research crackdown.
After the sixties,
the FDA had this advisory committee
meeting.
The National Institute of Drug Abuse
convened a meeting of their animal
researchers doing studies on
psychedelics and other drugs in animal
models trying to figure out what they
do.
They recommend that human use.
The advisory committee recommended that
human research be resumed and the FDA
adopted that so that we've actually had
this open door with a research at the
FDA if we had the resources except for
marijuana because marijuana was
controlled by the nationalist and of
drug abuse.
We had broken that.
We'd gotten her own supplies of
psychedelics after,
as their own supplies of psilocybin.
So now
the system takes,
um,
six to 10 years,
something like that,
of doing the research.
Once you have a drug that you think does
something to,
to prove it,
and that is take some time and it costs
a lot of money,
but it doesn't cost billions like the
pharmaceutical company will tell you.
I mean,
we're actually,
I'm able to make md man to a medicine in
part because it's a demonized drug
because it's ecstasy.
Governments over the world have spent
over $300,000,000,
probably more by now on research with
Mtma.
If you go into the scientific literature
and medline and you put in Mtma or
ecstasy,
there's over 5,000 papers.
A lot of science has been done but we
haven't had to pay for about the risks,
but even then when we sort of take that
and then do the kind of studies that we
needed to do with psychedelics,
it,
it feels like the system is takes time
to prove it,
but we are so good at tricking ourselves
and there is something to be said for
this process.
And so I think when we talk about how
come marijuana is into Madison,
part of it is that the process has been
gummed up for 50 years and is still
gummed up by this last step.
I mean there was another step that to
get access to this federal marijuana,
you had to have a public health service
review that was created in 1999 because
before that they only gave the marijuana
to government researchers.
You,
you couldn't even do your own funded
study with marijuana through the FDA
because you couldn't get the marijuana.
It was only for their researchers.
Ninety nine.
They created this policy that would open
it up in their minds,
but there was a special review in
addition to FDA.
Dea and Irb that,
that we just were able to succeed in
getting them to eliminate the Obama
administration eliminated it last
summer,
this public health service review.
It's what blocked our marijuana ptsd
study for years and years.
That's gone.
The last thing to get gone is this
government monopoly on marijuana and
we're working.
We're planning to resubmit an
application from professor craker.
We're working with Covington and burling
and big DC law firm taking the case pro
bono to um,
do a legal analysis and then we will try
to persuade.
We were working with Senator Gillibrand
and Senator Warren and others have been
engaging the dea and on DCP,
hhs,
human in discussions about this
monopoly.
There's growing support in Congress and
this is the last vestige of a sort of
politics blocking the science with
psychedelics or marijuana.
Then the system will have to work with
and in the meantime people can go around
and legalize and then that gets access.
And so we're not saying,
wait for the science to.
Well,
do you have any fear with the upcoming
elections?
Do you have any fear?
If we go right wing,
that there might be some blowback.
Yeah,
I mean I fearful that all the time.
I mean,
my,
my sort of core imprint was that in 1971
I first took lsd in 1972.
You know,
I decided that this was what I wanted to
devote my life to and I looked around
and I saw all the research has been shut
down.
I,
I sort of came in one year after the big
sweeping prohibition.
I woke up to it not when it was
thriving,
but right after the backlash.
That's why I think I was so motivated to
get involved with Mtma because I learned
about md may 19,
82 when it was an underground
psychedelic psychotherapy tool under the
code name Adam,
that the government had no knowledge of
in Dallas.
This was at Dallas.
I know Dallas is where Adam Mtma turned
into ecstasy,
so that's where they started selling it
above ground.
There's an incredible movie that's going
to come out,
the stork club about the club in Dallas
where it really got well known,
but it because it had this dual life,
one as this quiet underground therapy
drug with about half a million doses
having been used by around 1984 and then
the other was this public ecstasy use.
I thought,
okay,
now I know about it ahead of time.
I can see the crackdown coming.
Everybody could see the crackdown
coming,
but now we can organize.
Now we can have.
We can talk to people about it.
It's not a crime where we can gather our
forces and have people try it even,
and that's where I became really
politically
involved in the eighties.
Well,
it's just amazing how long it's taken,
but it's amazing that you have the
fortitude to push through for so long.
I mean the world,
the world and the consciousness of the
people.
Oh,
you guys a massive debt.
I mean a debt of gratitude for sure that
you've been out there pushing this
envelope and and chipping away.
It's like one of many weapons chipping
at this wall of ignorance,
but maps is a really powerful one.
And,
and we've been able to do it in a way
where right now we have two senior
retired FDA officials who are acting as
our consultants to prepare our documents
because they felt that there is a strong
need for new treatments for ptsd.
I mean they don't necessarily or saying
anything about cultural change or
spirituality or drug war.
There's this first soldiers just for
some other people,
everybody with ptsd that they,
they have watched over the last 15,
20 years what we've done.
And actually there's a woman on our
staff Ilsa Jerome that isn't been
reviewing all these papers,
all these 5,000 papers and developing
what's called a in conjunction with
other members of our team,
uh,
a investigator's brochure,
a summary of the literature with a risk
benefit calculation.
How you take all of this information.
And then what does it mean in terms of
the risks that you present to the
patients in the study and that you tell
the doctors and the people at the FDA
thought that we were doing it fairly in
a,
in a time when it was being distorted
and all these different ways and Elsa is
actually a little bit more conservative
than I am and I knew that it was kind of
good to let her take the lead and
writing this and that it got the respect
of the FDA.
So that's where I'm
hopeful that isn't it kind of strange
that a mtma being used to treat ptsd is
a primary motivating factor for the
federal government trying to make it
legal.
Because if you think about it,
ptsd,
PTSD is inexorably associated with war.
Yeah.
So,
so in some sort of strange way,
war was responsible for accelerating the
legalization of Mtma,
which is really fucking crazy.
I mean that is like the Yin and Yang in
like a bio mechanical form,
you know,
that's a kito yeah,
that's crazy.
If you really look at what that is.
Yeah.
No,
no.
We've also though,
what about the other,
the next step does we've been accused of
by our people have raised the cautionary
tale,
which I disagree with,
but they've said some people have said,
are you making it more easy to wage now
or if you are reducing the costs of war,
are you making war?
It's convoluted,
more likely have an option and I think
it's a worthwhile question to ask it.
It applies to all medical doctors that
worked for the military surgeons you
know are are you by treating people,
making it easier for there to be.
I think that's a very narrow
perspective.
It's a very narrow perspective and it's
also not taking into consideration the
actual psychoactive effects of that
substance because that's substance make
someone loving.
So if you think that giving out pills
that make you more loving or more likely
going to generate more war or make more
and more palatable,
I think the opposite is probably true.
I think the people who become more
loving who can relay the experiences of
the horrors of war to other people who
become more loving because they also get
a hold of this stuff,
then I think that's more likely to
eliminate war or lesson war or at least
mitigated significantly because I think
that war is probably mitigated
significant significantly now in
comparison to like the sheer numbers of
people like in comparison to,
you know,
500 years ago,
600 years ago.
It's probably way less war.
Yeah.
I just watched a lexus fella,
steven pinker just to.
Yes,
was very interesting about the reduction
of violence or the.
Well,
it's way easier.
It's way safer and I think that things
like psychedelic drugs in particular,
but also the meditative techniques,
focusing on being in the moment,
focusing on learning how to manage your
mind and there's a lot of things that
people are practicing and attempting to
to use in their everyday life today.
Mindfulness and it's,
it's,
it's a subject that's repeated very
often and people are trying to find a
better way of approaching different
dilemmas in their life and this is a
tool for those things.
It's a tool for those things that should
be considered alongside of yoga,
alongside of meditation,
alongside of Reading,
self help,
books alongside of having good friends
you can open up with and you can discuss
things together and get encouragement
from each other and and maybe even
criticism from each other and all those
things exist in,
in all sorts of different forums and
they exist in psychedelics as well.
A lot of the times.
I mean especially I find eating
marijuana to be one of the most self
analyzing,
objective,
introspective experiences you can have.
It's like a real wake up call to any
holes you might have in your game.
It just smacks you in the place and
sends you back out there in the world.
You're like,
shit,
okay,
I got it.
Those are tools and there's a.
they're all tools that can be used in a
variety of different ways,
but to deny the fact that they can be
used beneficially at this point is
really silly because we are finite
beings.
We live a short amount of time.
Wouldn't it be nice if you got rid of
most of your bullshit by the time you
hit add?
Yeah.
And it'd be nice.
This sense of,
isn't it,
about time that it is.
And I think there is a mainstream system
that's ready to incorporate that's
reaching out on the other side of yes.
And that this possibility of really
integrating this does seem to be the
case.
And I think with the military,
um,
I think that their training is to make
people who suppress their emotions and
to not feel the emotional consequences
to act in the heat of battle without the
emotions.
And I think with Mtma,
if you help people feel the emotional
consequences of their actions,
even if you've healed them from trauma
and they want to go back to their units,
that they are going to be more careful,
more sensitive,
they'll be.
I,
so I,
I have,
uh,
there's a German psychiatrist that I'm
Torsten Passie and he's sort of raised
this issue for me is what about the
concentration camp guards?
What if they were tormented and they
came to you for Mtma therapy,
you know,
you're a German therapist and they come
to you.
Why would you treat the concentration
camp people for their trauma?
And I think the question is,
are they,
are people who are worked with in this
emotional way for their trauma,
more or less likely to go back into
these situations that produced the
trauma in?
Well,
the question only becomes valid if you
think,
should you punish a person who's done
something like that in always forever or
should you try to make them better?
Right?
I mean,
did you not exonerating them for what
the horrible things they've done,
but should,
if you're going to keep them alive,
shouldn't you try to make them a better
person?
Do you have some sort of responsibility
to do that?
I would say the argument,
if you want to look at our civilization
and the like the most efficient manner I
want to look at it and I'm like,
what is the best way to get our
civilization together?
We'll have less assholes,
less crazy people,
let's mean people less,
you know,
less psychopathic fucking security
guards at Auschwitz.
So if you do have one,
you could probably get a lot of data
from studying that guy and he's
obviously going to be in jail for the
rest of his life.
Was not going to hurt.
Yeah,
I mean what,
what I was trying to say is what you do
that for an active military where they,
it's not historical,
but they'd go back and I'm saying,
I know that's like,
would you do it for a hobbit?
You know,
what you get on your fucking time
machine and traveled back to the Roman
days given to them.
Well,
you don't have to worry about that.
Do you have to worry about people today?
Right.
And I feel that trying to bring that up
healing approach,
that those loving feelings which Mtma
can really generate through oxytocin and
prolactin.
The hormone is released that are in
nursing and bonding Mtma releases those
hormones,
that drugs that women get when they
orgasm.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And actually tourists has written this
terrific paper about how organisms the
post orgasmic state and he's compared
the poster orgasmic state and the
hormonal release to Mtma.
And I think when we talk about Mtma,
a good way to think about it is the post
orgasmic state.
You're satiated,
your,
you're not striving.
Dude.
If you could come and it felt as good as
beyond ecstasy.
Let's not kid ourselves.
I don't know what come coming for.
That guy feels like he's.
Feels like he's coming on Mtma.
Alright dude.
Settle down.
If I'm buying it
door summit of Mt.
I'm exaggerating a little,
but it just,
I mean it feels real good.
MTMA feels like you're not even here in
some the planet love,
you know,
I only did it once,
did it once to two pills.
Super powerful stuff.
The next day I was wrecked the.
That was not worth it for me.
I definitely learned a lot from the
experience,
but the next day was absolutely
horrendous.
Well,
it's probably horrendous because you
wanted to do things.
When we talk about people to.
We're thinking about Mtma,
what we say is don't do anything else.
It's a two day experience.
You need the second day to rest and
reflect and again,
what's the purpose of it?
If you're trying to have this
experiences,
loving experience and then kind of bring
appropriate some of that into your daily
life learning integrated.
Then the very next day is one of the
most important parts because you're
still halfway in,
halfway out,
you're able to think about it.
That's where a lot of the integration
work gets done.
So in our therapy we make it so that
people spend the night in the treatment
center just so that they don't have to
move,
they don't have to get distracted and
then there's hours of psychotherapy the
next day to help them integrate it and
then when they go home we call them
everyday on the of per week on the phone
just to check in and see how they're
doing.
So it's rick,
Rick,
Rick Doblin,
Woodside.
I feel like I just came all the time.
All the time,
Bro.
Alright man,
peace out.
We've got to wrap this up man.
Unfortunately we started a little late
and I gotta get Outta here.
Okay.
Um,
is there anything you can direct people
towards a website which is maps.org?
Yes.
And in fact we're having our 30th
anniversary celebration on Sunday,
April 17th and we're live streaming it
for free.
So it's maps.org/.
Um,
how are you going to know when people
are Dea agents undercover?
They're well tie clips actually.
Um,
we have our first reach senior retired
dea consultant and Martin man and smart.
But again,
it's compassion.
I mean he had a son who I'm listed in
the army and has ptsd and is 50 percent
disabled from ptsd
and is found marijuana to be helpful
again,
isn't it?
That's what.
Yeah,
that,
those,
those kinds of stories that helped me
think that we can do this integration.
We can and I am worried about right wing
backlash,
but there's a couple of things that
we've put into place.
First off,
to work with the military,
I mean,
right when gloves in the military,
if we're trying to help the military,
there's also people are compassionate
about a childhood sexual abuse survivors
and so
I think that we have enough of a base of
evidence and a long pattern since 1992
of the precedents at the FDA that I
think we could survive.
The FDA also recently did something very
interesting with the abortion pill.
Are you 46 that they made it easier on
women.
They eliminated one required step that
the science showed that they didn't need
and so the FDA is very much trying to be
science over politics.
I mean they,
they will have an FDA commissioner
that's appointed by and confirmed by
president,
but at the same time the people that are
there are really focused on science over
politics and compassion.
The other part is that we have
international strategy.
When was the last time anybody ever
talked over the music?
Oh,
it was awesome.
Awesome information.
I wish you didn't have it,
but I really do.
Thank you very much.
Hashtag psychedelic because tail.
It's like a dog because what does that
mean?
No,
don't say it.
Don't stop.
I got to go to maps.org.
And the uh,
the party one more time is April 17th.
April 17th.
In Oakland.
Where?
At Scottish rite temple.
What time does it start?
It starts from five to 11.
And tickets at the door.
Um,
you know,
not for,
for the evening part,
but not for the banquet.
So you got to go to maps.org and you saw
that information.
Thank you.
Beautiful.
Thank you sir.
Much appreciated.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen.
That's it for the week.
See you soon.
Bye.